devons considérer que les chiffres sont
sous-estimés mais nous ne sommes pas
encore au niveau où se trouve par
exemple l'europe ou les états unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus au nord proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement plus être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
que si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les titres de ce mardi nous au
rassemblement et hommage ce soir dans
l'hexagone pour saluer la mémoire de
zhangzhou floyd et combattre le racisme
dans la police
nous irons place de la république dans
quelques instants alors qu'edouard finit
plus appel au respect à la confiance
mais aussi l exigence vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre lendemain des mesures
dévoilées par son ministre de
l'intérieur
hommage aux français au moment donc nous
se déroulent les funérailles de djordje
floyd dans l'intimité à houston mais ils
sont également venus nombreux se
recueillir en sa mémoire dans sa ville
natale depuis la mort de cet homme
afro-américains fixiez par un policier
le 25 mai les appels à réformer la
police se multiplient partout aux états
unis ce qui fragilise la campagne de
donald trump au profit de son rival
jobbes ivn la crise du coronavirus si
l'europe commence à souffler l'amérique
latine elle est frappée de plein fouet
par l'épidémie
le brésil est le troisième pays le plus
touché au monde avec plus de 37 mille
décès et d'autres comme le chili et le
pérou sont aussi confrontés un système
de santé défaillant au manque de test ou
bien encore à des choix politiques
[Musique]
paris lille grenoble dijon ou encore
amiens après les mobilisations de la
semaine dernière nouveau rassemblement
et hommage dans plusieurs villes de
france aujourd'hui le rendez vous était
fixé à 18h pile heure à laquelle ont
débuté précisément les obsèques de
giorgio floyd de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
plusieurs syndicats partis politiques
organisations étudiantes et lycéennes
ong se sont associés à l'appel à
manifester lancé par sos racisme pour
combattre le racisme dans la police dans
la capitale rassemblement dont 15 place
de la république où nous retrouvons en
direct sur place katia pique nique
bonsoir katia est ce qu'il y a du monde
sur place
[Musique]
stéphanie vais écouter le rassemblement
va se disperser mais il ya toujours
énormément de monde sur la place
inconnue était la fréquentation est ce
que vraiment les gens allaient se
déplace eh bien oui il a eu énormément
des milliers de personnes pour honorer
la mémoire de georges feuilles
d'aujourd'hui pour cet appel est lancé
par sos racisme alors évidemment outre
les citoyens de nombreuses associations
antiracistes étaient présents des partis
politiques comme le parti communiste et
puis de nombreux élus le sénateur
socialiste assouline par exemple mais il
y avait de très très nombreuses écharpe
dans cette assemblée très solennelle ça
a débuté par une co prise de parole
ensuite deschamps et puis huit minutes
46 de silence avec un genou à terre pour
la plupart des personnes qui étaient
rassemblés ici huit minutes 46 vous le
savez un c'est la durée pendant laquelle
georges floyd a été maintenu au sol le
cou compressés par le genou de derek
chauvin des des longues minutes pendant
lesquelles il a supplié qu'on le laisse
respirer donc je peux vous dire qu'en
effet c'est 8 min 46 et est longue mais
en tout cas une grande solennité
aujourd'hui à dents sur cette place de
la république
en effet ce temps font clairement le
lien entre la situation aux états unis
et ce qui se passe en france
oui alors en effet c'est sûr qu'on ne
pouvait pas s'y tromper en lisant les
très nombreuses pancartes 1 il y avait
de très nombreuses connotation des
allusions à la violence policière en
france avec les nom d'adama les noms de
cédric joue via et un appel au calme à
l'arrêt des violences et l'arrêt du
racisme également en france alors je
vous propose d'écouter certaines
personnes certains certaines personnes
rassemblées ici et qui nous ont répondu
à nos questions
si on a tenu à organiser cet hommage
avec autant de jeunes aujourd'hui à 18
heures place de la république c'est
parce qu'en même temps à 11h à houston
était organisé les obsèques de georges
floyd noir mort parce que noir par un
représentant de l'état par un policier
aux états unis même si ça s'est passé
aux états unis
ça a cristallisé une émotion et une
colère particulière en france puisque
nous jeunes en france nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas hors sujet de ce
phénomène qu'est le racisme dans la
police c'était normal d'être là contre
ce racisme contre 7 ses façons de faire
autoritaire de la police ça fait un clin
d'oeil à ce qui se passe aussi en france
même si les choses sont pas les mêmes
néanmoins moi je suis élue de
seine-saint-denis on peut pas dire que
tout se passe dans le meilleur des
mondes
la police est une la sécurité est un
droit essentiel
ça touche les plus faibles la police se
doit être exemplaire et quand on est
exemplaire
on peut pas être le visage de penser
beaucoup plus médiatisée qu'avant et du
coup il ya un réveil des débris par
rapport à l'association auxilia a entre
guillemets toujours existé et elle assez
prépondérante et aux états unis
mais aussi en france à l'égard des
minorités de manière générale je pense
qu'il ya un mouvement historique qui est
en train de s'établir pour la première
fois dans toute l'humanité voire de tous
les pays on se rend compte enfants qu'
il n'y a plus de place à la
discrimination quelle qu'elle soit plus
place à l'antisémitisme plus de place
aux assises tout le monde se mobilise et
s'élève d'un seul d'un seul homme pour
dire non pour dire que voilà on a connu
une période très dure au niveau de la
pandémie qui n'est pas terminée et que
l'humanité a pris le dessus sur j'espère
le capitalisme et que c'est plus
possible actuellement d'énigmes de
dénigrer le mans voyez l'ambiance était
certes très solennelle mais aussi à la
combativité
en tout cas là sur cette place le
rassemblement se disperse lentilles mans
et dante mans et dans le plus grand
calme car les organisateurs ont bien
tenu à insister il faut garder comme ils
ont dit notre dignité et notre pacifisme
merci katia technique et côté réactions
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec mais les rangs de saint-just
président du groupe rassemblement
national au conseil régional
d'ile-de-france bonsoir en vénérant de
saint-just merci avec nos rouge en
direct sur rt france alors que vous
inspirent ces hommages en france à la
mémoire de cette américaine chargers
floyd écouter dans ces manifestations il
ya certains certainement à chacun donc
de manifestants de de bonne foi et nous
nous rejetons évidemment tour haschich
tout antisémitisme
c'est clair mais c'est quand même gênant
c'est que elles sont à l'initiative de
la famille traoré est né alors cette
famille n'a pas l'air vraiment en fait
digne de monter ce manifestation
premièrement deux errements qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement dans la
sphère de adama
traoré on ne sait pas sauf qu'on sait
qu'il ya deux expertises judiciaires qui
met en cause peut être totalement hors
de cause les gendarmes
il faut savoir raison garder et ne pas
aller proclamer comme ne font un certain
nombre d' excités qui sont dans ces
manifestations qui les soutiennent que
la police française est raciste que la
france est un pays de racisme systémique
tout ça est entièrement fausses et
diffamatoires c'est scandaleux
nous sommes le pays peut être le moins
raciste du monde et la police française
et la police certainement la moins
raciste du monde
alors va les rendre saint-just
effectivement vous nous dit tiens il ya
deux expertises qui dédouane totalement
les forces de l'ordre il n'empêche une
troisième expertise indépendante cette
fois lancée par la famille traoré qui
justement incrimine cette fois ci les
forces de l'ordre vous comprenez tout de
même la colère de cette famille que vous
jugez jeu les relevés a dit mme de
lancer ces informations à ces
manifestations
donc ces deux questions peut-être en une
mais voilà cette expertise et cette
famille quand même qui est en colère
supposons qu'ils aient cette troisième
expertise que l'on puisse à considérer
qu'elle n'ait pas été ordonnées
judiciairement exécrable et le problème
supplémentaire des dossiers et dans
beaucoup de dossiers de ce genre si la
lenteur et l'incapacité de la justice
je crois que le drame qui a affecté
adama traoré 7 2016 nous sommes en 2020
que font les juges etc dans toutes les
affaires pareilles alors en france la
justice n'a aucun moyen et des juges ne
veulent pas travailler en plus ils ont
peur ils ont peur une heure de trouille
comme non comme nos politiques
d'ailleurs comme nos scénaristes
ils sont tétanisés par la peur de
l'accusation de racisme ou de
discrimination
or il faut que tu fasses chartres à dry
est fautif à asseoir travail 8
une famille comme la famille traoré ce
soit celle là avec ce qu'on peut penser
ou d'autres familles de victimes de
notre de deux tu peux y arriver avec le
policier ces choix peuvent être très
rapidement mis au courant de ce qui se
passe du bourde contre des
responsabilités et que la pole il ajoute
il fasse son travail
vous savez dans un grand nombre de
situations politiques sociales de notre
pays s'en va mal parce que de pouvoirs
régaliens justice ne fait pas son
travail voilà et dans de nombreux cas ça
irait beaucoup mieux si elle le faisait
son travail
alors ce soir la république en marche à
travers un tweet a appelé à se
recueillir en la mémoire de zhangzhou
floyd a de son côté le miz de
l'intérieur indiqué qu'il n'y aurait pas
de sanction pour les manifestations non
autorisées on rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
pas plus de dix personnes sont
autorisées dans l'espace public en
raison de la crise sanitaire ça vous
inspire quoi cette indulgence de la part
de christophe castaner ça aussi c'est
castaner tétanisés par la peur qu'elle
avait fait n'importe quoi on ne peut pas
on ne peut jamais quand on est mise à
terre abandonnée l'état de droit et si
on n'a pas droit de manifester on ne
manifeste pas et il ya une infraction
qui s'appelle le participation à une
manifestation interdite et il faut faire
passer les engueulades et y soit jugé du
poids qu'il soit condamné mais au moins
qu'il soit jugé que mr l'intérieur façon
à semblant de faire quelque chose
alors il ya aussi une cacophonie
incroyable sein du gouvernement
testan air avec son chrono de 2 ce matin
où il tient je n'ai plus le moindre
soupçon à gérer de racisme chez les
policiers entraînera une suspension
immédiate
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pas suspendre
les gens comme ça soupçons avérés 5 à
lima tient incroyable alors il ya
castaner qui s'agenouille et notamment
aux sages ou que je vends ce qu'ils
achètent la police et en même temps il
doit philippe qui dit ce choix il faut
beaucoup de respect à l'égard des de la
police aidée des gendarmes et des forces
de l'ordre en france ou est ce
gouvernement que fait ce gouvernement
sont encore une fois tétanisés alors
qu'il faut appliquer l'état de droit
appliqué les règles régaliennes et
demander notamment dans des drames comme
la sotra aurait parce que quand même un
homme est mort et il ya des éléments qui
ferait tout
de l'origine de la ba que la justice
dise rapidement que progra les
instructions de lâche 1,10 rapidement ce
qu'il en est et qu' il est un tribunal
qu'ils soient saisis hier votre parti
par la voix de jordan bardella estimé
que emmanuel macron et christophe
castaner lâcher la police et la
gendarmerie et que c'était leur rôle au
contraire de les soutenir c'est votre
analyse également
c'est extrêmement grave personne n'est
capable de mettre en cause les forces de
l'ordre dans la ferte de monsieur adama
traoré
premièrement deuxièmement nous avons une
police la police je le répète des forces
de vente ou moins racistes du monde
il peut toujours exister des incidents
bien si donc on appelle des bavures
quand on est en face de bajur on les
fait traiter encore une fois très
rapidement par la justice et si le
policier où les policiers sont coupables
à la moi je suis d'accord pour lé que
les sanctions soit absolument exemplaire
ps pardonnez-moi mais la third adama
traoré qui aujourd'hui décline
l'invitation de la ministre de la
justice elle a bien fait parce que tout
simplement il ya une séparation des
pouvoirs vont au contraire elle aurait
dû y aller elle a bien fait enfin bon là
elle est très intelligente et en même
temps très politique
c'est complètement ridicule de la part
de madame b double risque d'abord de la
part de google de qualité et
deuxièmement contre la constitution
entre la séparation des pouvoirs c'est
pas madame b to b qui doivent savoir
mademoiselle traoré ce sont deux ans
d'instruction et le procureur de paris
pour lui dire voilà ce qu'il ya dans la
procédure et on vous promet on va aller
vite qu'on va vite ça tu as fait c'est
ça qu'il faut faire vite cattani malgré
ce qu'on peut en penser
en tout cas adama traoré est mort
merci les rentes st juste d'avoir été
avec nous président du groupe
rassemblement national au conseil
régional d'île de france et dans ce
contexte de dénonciation des violences
policières
gouvernement s'affiche mobiliser un mot
d'ordre depuis hier tolérance zéro
contre le racisme edouard philippe et
christophe castaner était à evry à la
rencontre des policiers qui travaillent
dans les quartiers difficiles
le premier ministre reconnaît une
émotion très grande très légitime est
très partagée vis-à-vis des violences
policières
leur mission
c'est souvent d'être des femmes et des
hommes confrontés à des tensions à des
menaces a dit risque c'est parfois être
l'objet de mises en cause ou d' attaques
physiques
ce matin je suis en essonne dans un
département ou à de nombreuses reprises
les forces de l'ordre les gardiens de la
paix ont été victimes d'attaqués
physiques terry gardiens de la paix les
forces de l'ordre qui assure notre
protection
nous leur devons respect et confiance
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
l'immense majorité des français a
vis-à-vis de nos forces de l'ordre de
nos gardiens de la paix respect et
confiance
et parce que nous devons avoir respect
et confiance à des femmes et des hommes
qui s'engagent dans des missions
redoutablement difficile est essentielle
nous avons également un devoir
d'exigence vis-à-vis d'elle vis-à-vis de
la vérité c'est que le racisme est une
une forme de maladie de l'âme une forme
de faiblesse
on peut toujours pointer la faiblesse
des autres et il faut la dénoncer
il faut savoir que c'est au moins autant
un combat individuel puis d'affaires de
combat collectif
il faut savoir que nous devons tous être
à la hauteur des principes de la
république
en étant exigeant vis-à-vis de ce qu'ils
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
comme en étant exigeant vis-à-vis de
soi-même en étant confiant aussi on ne
rentrant pas dans des amalgames qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être
en défendant les principes de notre
république en défendant les institutions
de notre république en disant notre
confiance et notre respect aux forces de
l'ordre gardiens de la paix aux
associations aussi à toutes celles et
tous ceux qui se battent pour que les
beaux principes qui sont les nôtres des
meilleurs merveilleux principes qui sont
les nôtres ou deviennent des règles de
vie et puis ce être mises en oeuvre tous
les jours partout en france dans de
bonnes conditions
la police française n'est pas la police
américaine c'est ce qu'a précisé hier
christophe castaner alors sont elles
vraiment différente et de police quid de
leurs méthodes d'interpellation les
mêmes questions de déontologie ce post
elle en france et outre atlantique c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec alexandre l'endroit
secrétaire général du syndicat vigie
police bonsoir alexandre l'envoi merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés rust
président de l'association banlieues
actives bonsoir à vous ross merci
également d'être en direct une réaction
pour commencer sur cette déclaration du
ministre de l'intérieur la france ce
n'est pas l'amérique
il a raison alexandre langlois oui la
raison la france ce n'est pas l'amérique
là bas en france dans une police
nationale la bassée plus des polices
municipales ou d'état la barre les
personnes face à la police peuvent être
armés tout parce qu'un port d'armes
autorisée en france n'est pas le cas des
gens qui nous avons en face de nous donc
effectivement et ça n'a rien à voir les
règles d'usagé des armes ne sont pas les
mêmes le contexte la population donc ces
deux mondes différents et on peut
trouver quelques similitudes rost
d'accord avec ce diagnostic bon sac et
pour le coup factuel mais c'est vrai que
on tente aujourd'hui effectivement cet
amalgame d'aider ce qui se passe outre
atlantique et en france
est ce que vous êtes en accord avec ça
en effet distinguer le fait de pointer
du doigt les bavures policières et le
fait qu'il y ait un système qui soit
pratique ça depuis très longtemps
aux états unis il ya mille personnes qui
meurent tous les ans milne loire qui
sont tués tous les ans par la police
donc en france
évidemment on n'est pas assez niveau à
ce niveau là mais il y à des bavures et
lorsqu'on parle de similitudes c'est
plus là dessus que le que le système en
tant que tel est-ce qu'on a tout de même
alexandre l'emploi les mêmes techniques
en france qui mène aux mêmes scènes
d'interpellations pensons évidemment à
la faire chaud via un plaquage ventrale
c'était en janvier dernier qui a mené à
son décès nous recevons d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure son père à 21h est-ce que tout
de même c'est comparable pour le coup
chaque pays a ses méthodes par contre ce
qui est comparable c'est qu'il ya des
résultats catastrophiques de chaque côté
de l'atlantique
donc chacun avec ses méthodes qui
peuvent être différentes et donc dans la
sphère se souvient effectivement il y
avait des méthodes d'interpellation en
appuyant sa cage thoracique qui ont mené
au décès de monsieur souvient qu'ils
sont catastrophiques ça ne devrait pas
exister dans un pays comme la france
surtout je le rappelle pour un contrôle
routier circa pas mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui y avait pas un braquage
il faut aussi à savoir de quoi on parle
c'est aussi le problème de l'hygiène qui
n'a aucun rôle pédagogique qui dit il ya
tant de personnes tuées par la police
chaque année voilà mais sans
différencier par exemple le cas de
monsieur chou via de le cas d'un
terroriste qui a été abattu donc ça
c'est dramatique
donc ne mélangeons pas tout les cas
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur
veut réformer la formation et les
méthodes d'interpellation c'est tant
mieux
mais est ce qu'on va pouvoir croire
quelqu'un qui ment depuis le début de
son mandat
mais tant d'acteurs des actes forts la
seule chose qu'on a pu voir de forts
aujourd'hui c'est que bach en a eu lieu
à des placements evry c'est bien le
premier ministre qui est venu mon ami
monsieur castaner derrière pour pas
qu'ils disent encore des bêtises voilà
donc c'est peut-être un premier single
on espère que maintenant la suite va
continuer pour qu'ils aient des avancées
concrètes à la fois pour les policiers
la population et qu'on puisse regagner
un climat de confiance qui est très
compliqué à l'heure actuelle la loi
avant de faire évidemment réagir aussi
rapidement parce que c'est important dit
il ment depuis le début il raconte des
bêtises vous pensez à quoi précisément
gilet jaune n'y a pas de violences
policières il n'y a pas de mutilés il
n'y a pas dans un état droit ce n'est
pas possible ne connaît pas de policiers
qu'on fait des violences alors que ces
policiers sont protégés par
l'institution policière
on a bien vu qui a aucune des poursuites
qui sont arrivés et c'est par exemple
pour le cas de cédric du pompier à lyon
c'est olivier béziade c'était le monde
le journal le monde qui a fait une
enquête plus rapidement que l'igpn est
le choix du ministère ça a été de
promouvoir le préfet de police
l'allemand qui étaient là bas et qui a
couvert ces agissements préfet de police
de paris
donc voilà la deuxième chose d'également
sur leur pastis mme dans la police parce
qu'en fait le racisme on parle du
racisme de la police il ya des racistes
dans la police et des collègues en sont
victimes
je rappellerai que c'est pas un problème
nouveau en 2012 2010 il ya deux
collègues entier qui s'est suicidé la
force de sécurité [ __ ] par son
commandant de compagnie
la sanction administrative du commandant
a fait c'est pas bien pour pas
recommencer voilà et la chose encore
plus récente début de l'année notre
collègue nova noir qui a dénoncé des
agissements racistes à son encontre et à
l'encontre de d'autres collègues et bien
le choix du ministre de l'intérieur ça
n'a pas été de régler et de poursuivre
les auteurs de ces actes étaient de
poursuivre notre délégué parce qu'il
avait dénoncé sur la place publique pour
manque de loyauté envers la police
donc tant qu'on est dans cette chape de
plomb ça n'avancera pas en fait cirque
les lanceurs dallaire dans la police
sont sanctionnés à l'heure actuelle donc
effectivement monsieur castaner pour le
moment n'a pas fait d'excusés à notre
délégué n'a pas poursuivi les personnes
mises en cause deuxième et dernier point
aussi c'est sur la terre de roi soleil a
eu des échanges waza par ou avec des
propos très racistes etc
le ministre de l'intérieur notre délégué
dans un manoir donc qui a été sanctionné
avait dit ils seront toujours en poste
dans des années à venir
et là ils vont enfin passer en conseil
de discipline au bout de six mois sans
avoir été suspendu et en ayant assuré la
sécurité de madame belloubet quand les
s'est déplacé au tj d'euros il ya
quelques jours
qu'est-ce que vous inspirent les propos
d'alexandre langlois qui n'est pas ton
effectivement avec le ministre de
l'intérieur vous il vous a plutôt
satisfait hier lors de sa conférence de
presse avec ces énoncés et la prise en
compte
effectivement d'un problème de racisme
chez certains policiers
c'était plutôt satisfaisant écoutez moi
un jeu franchement si on avait eu des
personnes comme monsieur langlois
il ya quelques années de ça on aurait
vite et certainement beaucoup de mutiler
et beau
de bavures policières et certainement
aussi des morts donc je tiens à le
remercier de parler aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est à une période très
historique
vraiment j'ai comme des millions de
français
au lendemain des attentats de charlie
hebdo et ceux qui ont suivi comme
renault j'ai embrassé un flic et on
était heureux de notre police on l'était
on était fier on l'a défendu on à porter
haut ses couleurs sur toutes ces
périodes là et puis quelques temps après
les le quotidien a repris le dessus et
les comportements déviants de certains
encore une fois il s'agit pas et moi je
l' ai toujours dit c'est un combat que
je mène depuis très longtemps et ce qui
est important
si j'ai toujours dit que la police
française est à l'image de la france de
même société
c'est à dire qu'il y a des gens bien
vous avez aussi une petite frange de
brebis galeuses au même titre que dans
nos quartiers vous avez aussi qu'une
petite frange qui fout le bordel et d'où
il faut faire le ménage et ses
impératifs
le discours du ministre hier on dit les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui y
croient
moi je suis devenu un peu comme saint
thomas genevois
je ne crois que ce que je vois donc
attendons de voir réellement et
concrètement ce qui va être fait avant
de crier victoire
tous ces déplacements la déplacements
qui sont faits actuellement tous et
toute cette agitation
elle vise à quoi à calmer les choses
pour éviter que les banlieues ne
s'embrase mais ils savent en plus que ce
n'est pas il n'y a pas que les banlieues
qui risque de s'embraser
parce que vous avez les effets du co
vide qui vont arriver dont très peu de
ton avec cette france qui va être
licencié massivement avec ceux qui vont
fermer leur petit business ainsi de
suite et tout ça est en train de
s'agréger sur une colère contre un
gouvernement qui jusqu'à présent étaient
dans le mépris dans le déni et de tout
ce qui se passait et des réalités que
certains d'entre nous qui sommes sur le
terrain tous les jours et ce en essayant
de porter en étant les conques du
silence de la masse silencieuse qui ne
s'exprime pas qu'on n'entend pas alors
messieurs je voulais vous faire réagir
sur cette déclaration
d'olivier marchal vous savez cet ancien
flic un passé on le sait dans le monde
du cinéma le réalisateur de 36 quai des
enfers il était l'invité d'une chaîne de
télé française hier et il a piqué un
coup de colère écouter quand on choisit
le métier de flic
on le choisit pour servir et protéger
j'ai été flic pendant 12 ans je n'ai pas
fait flics pour casser de l'arabe et du
noir tous les flics qui rentre dans la
police veulent servir et protéger
alexandre loi va le servir et protéger
allez monsieur marshall qui vit aussi
les flics sont devenus un petit peu les
boucs émissaires ça vous inspire quoi
justement cette remarque d'olivier
marchal de défendre quand même
effectivement ses anciens collègues
sam aspire deux choses la première c'est
que malheureusement il y à des policiers
qui rentre avec de mauvaises intentions
dans la police nationale
et malheureusement cette minorité n'est
pas filtrée au niveau du concours
d'entrée et ce qui se passe depuis que
monsieur macro et président de la
république
le concours il la première année il ya
eu 300 personnes qui n'ont pas pu être
pris longtemps la police pas 300 kw à ce
qu'ils n'ont pas été pourvus parce que
il n'y avait pas des gens qui avaient le
niveau pour passer le concours on est
descendu à 8 de moyenne l'année suivante
on s'est dit on va augmenter les
salaires en début sur salariale pour
attirer des personnes qui ont le niveau
pour passer le concours
la mesure qui a été prise a été entre de
baisser le niveau du concours de
toujours prendre à 8 de moyenne et mais
malgré cela voilà il y avait 200 postes
non pourvus à tel point que le directeur
de l'information
monsieur lutz on est alarmé dans le
journal le monde en disant qu'il ne
pourrait rien faire des personnes qu'on
lui envoie la deuxième chose aussi c'est
là je raconte est aussi un encadrement
et une difficulté c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de policiers qui arrive en
ile-de-france dans des capacités de
difficile et qu'ils ne sont pas formés à
arriver dans ces quartiers là c'est
malheureusement pour la police mais dans
le cas de beaucoup de postes dans la
fonction publique j'ai des amis dans
l'éducation nationale qui me racontent
la même chose est en fait ya des choses
qui s'appelle avec l'expérience de la
vie on ne réagit pas de la même façon à
20 ans 30 ans 40 ans et avec le recul et
ben on arrive par exemple tout feu tout
flamme à 20 ans on se dit ouah je vais
faire comme à bfmtv je vais tout casser
je vais révolutionner jeu jouent aux cow
boy
la réalité c'est pas ça il y avait des
anciens qu'avait
du plan de relève qui disaient non on va
discuter le but du jeu c'est d'apaiser
les choses de faire de la prévention
on fait de la répression que quand c'est
nécessaire et à l'heure actuelle ce
n'est pas le cas donc olivier marchal
essaye de défendre la boutique c'est
très bien malheureusement la police a
évolué et la police qui l'a connu
n'évolue pas forcément dans le temps
enfin la police actuel n'est pas
forcément celle qu'il a connue
malheureusement alors par contre il a
raison sur une chose c'est une minorité
de policiers nous on en veut énormément
à notre hiérarchie qui ne fait pas le
ménage dans nos rangs et qui poursuit
les gens voient la roste le mot de la
fin sur ces remarques
écoutez moi je franchement je pense que
vraiment à tout point de vue on est dans
une période historique entendre ce genre
de discours mais vous même les
journalistes de coûts en navette vous
pas de donner la parole à ces gens là on
aurait évité beaucoup de drames
j'insiste dessus et donc aujourd'hui la
chai de là je vous attaquent un peu
volontairement mais voilà mais c'est
vrai que nous faisons entrer menton on a
essayé d'organiser des débats entre la
police les jeunes au moment de la
suppression de la police de proximité
je fais partie de ceux qu'ont lancé une
pétition pour rétablir une autre vision
de la police que celle qui est là juste
pour faire de la répression
et aujourd'hui on a cette chance malgré
tout malgré les drames parfois il faut
ça pour peut-être améliorer les choses
posons nous nous sommes en train de
mettre en place un gros événement très
prochainement pour essayer de renouer le
lien de recréer du dialogue et voir
comment on peut sortir des belles choses
de ce qui est en train de se passer à
travers ces drames
merci on terminera sur cette note
positive merci à tous les deux d'avoir
été en direct avec nous hélas tu es avec
nous dans quelques instants ou partiront
justement aux états unis où les
funérailles de zhangzhou floyd se
déroule dans l'intimité à houston deux
semaines après la mort de ce chef
américain lors de son interpellation
direction ensuite un petit peu plus au
sud en amérique latine longtemps on
l'europe commence à souffler faso on a
viré son temps le brésil ou encore le
chili
dans une situation catastrophique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale
quel rôle doit selon vos jouets à lévis
mais quel rôle joue-t-elle dans les
faits les villes tout comme les états
ils étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques des matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment est
ce qu'elles peuvent transformer après la
pandémie la crise maintenant à fait bien
comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier des
banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle ne part pas seulement d'elle même
elle parle aussi de comment créer un
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france 20h30 heure de paris une
journée particulière aux états unis avec
les funérailles de georgia floyd cet
homme désormais symbole de la lutte
antiraciste et qui met en ce moment à
houston la ville où il a grandi
des funérailles privées mais beaucoup
d'américains ont tenu à lui rendre
hommage dans les rues et hier des
milliers d'anonymes ont également bravé
la chaleur pour venir saluer sa
dépouille exposée à l'intérieur d'une
église à houston écoute ma gueule oh mon
dieu il a l'air en paix même si nous
savons ce qui s'est passé mais de la
façon dont ils ont fait des choses
il a l'air en paix il a l'air calme et
il a l'air plutôt ils ont fait du bon
travail
vraiment on voudrait passer un peu plus
de temps avec lui juste lui montrer
notre respect et être près de lui avoir
un moment avec lui mais c'est si court
mais je suis vraiment contente d'être
venue
on a fait la queue pendant plus de cinq
six heures et je suis vraiment super
content d'être venu
ça valait le coup c'est un sentiment
d'euphorie parce que ça arrive trop tard
pour les personnes noires ça dépasse le
décès de georges fleuve ça dépasse le
quartier dans lequel il a grandi ça
dépasse l'église il est temps de mettre
fin à l'oppression des personnes noires
regardez c'est houston texas nous sommes
le melting pas des états unis si vous
voyez des gens ici noir blanc
hispaniques asiatiques du moyen-orient
européen
tout le monde est là en paix pour
célébrer une vie qui n'aurait pas dû
être perdus et pour voir l'esprit
américain de l'action nous sommes très
enthousiastes et le procès de derek
chauvin a débuté hier accusé du meurtre
de djordje flou et sa caution a été
fixée à un million
dollar il comparaissait pour la première
fois devant une juge par vidéoconférence
il est incarcéré dans une prison
fédérale de haute sécurité eris jusqu'à
40 ans de réclusion trois de ses anciens
collègues présents lors de l'arrestation
elles sont inculpés de complicité de
meurtre la date de la prochaine audience
a été fixée au 29 juin et à la fin du
mois de mai les manifestations contre la
mort de zhangzhou floyd ont provoqué des
heurts dont différentes villes des états
unis ce n'est pas la première fois que
des émeutes raciales éclate après des
bavures policières
retour en images
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dre pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis minneapolis avec dave be king
membre du conseil d'administration des
communautés unis contre la brutalité
policière c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir dave b-king
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france vous êtes précisément à
minneapolis une ville recueillies en ce
moment même à l'heure des funérailles de
giorgio floyd on imagine une émotion
palpable sur place effectivement il y a
une notion très vives
pour georges flotte mais également il ya
beaucoup de colère et de détermination
afin de réagir d'amener la justice pour
josh l'oeil mais également afin de
changer le système qui a permis cette
tragédie
donc il ya encore beaucoup de
manifestations en prévoit encore
davantage et beaucoup de personnes
souhaitent ceux des réformes majeures
dans le département de police
nous n'avons plus d'un cent dix n'y a
plus de pillages mais je pense que la
détermination est toujours aussi forte
et que les gens sont très rassemblée
effectivement on a vu des images fortes
en faire le tour du monde celle de ces
femmes de ses hommes un genou à terre
ces images selon vous est-ce que vous
avez bon espoir qu'elle soit vraiment
suivies d'effet les actions ne découle
pas directement des images a également
je ne sais pas si vous faisait référence
à des agents de police qui s'agenouille
pour jon voight mais en tout cas cela
est très hypocrite il la sage nous dans
la rue c'est très important et cela fait
partie deux du mouvement demande de
l'action mais cette action de solidarité
de la police est un
mauvais message parce que tout cela a
commencé par un agent de police qui
s'agenouillaient sur quelqu'un pour nous
les la police n'est pas notre allié ce
sont des obstacles à la réforme ils ont
été pendant très longtemps donc l'action
devra intervenir et venir d'ailleurs
parce que les citoyens veulent ériger
grâce à leurs manifestations et à
travers beaucoup de solidarité et
beaucoup d'activisme et de pression en
somme en regroupant une une forme de
sévérité en vis-à-vis de la police dans
son ensemble c'est vrai qu'en france on
a ce débat aujourd'hui aussi tout le
monde s'accorde à dire voilà qu'il ya du
racisme dans la police mais que la
police n'est pas raciste
la situation selon vous est plus
compliquée aux états unis avec avec la
police oui c'est certain effectivement
la situation est différente de ce que
vous avez été car beaucoup de policiers
sont racistes sont explicitement raciste
il s'utilise des termes racistes et les
statistiques montrent qu'il vise les
personnes de couleur bien plus que les
personnes de couleur blanche donc il ya
des personnes racistes au sein de la
police mais les institutions elles mêmes
sont également raciste
la police est conçu afin de maintenir un
état de fait
un système qui renforce des disparités
raciales en matière d'éducation d'emploi
et de justice en tant qu'institution la
police a été conçu afin de maintenir ce
statu quo est d'empêcher le changement
dans beaucoup de domaines différents
le système policier et racisme par
définition vous parlez de réforme de la
police que vous appeliez de vos voeux
tout à l'heure à minneapolis
il semblerait que ça soit le cas puisque
la police apparemment a été démantelé
c'est vraiment une première étape qui
laisse de l'espoir pour vous il ya des
signes d'espoir dans le sens
les gens demandent le démantèlement de
la police mais les plutôt malheureuse
heureusement heureusement les membres de
notre conseil municipal ont décidé de
démanteler ou en tout cas de couper les
fonds du département de police ils ont
été un problème pendant des années des
années et ces mêmes personnes disaient
on ne peut pas faire de réformes ya trop
d'obstacles les obstacles au
démantèlement de la police sont bien
plus importants et il faudra des années
avant de l'accomplir
il utilise cette idée afin de repousser
la discussion sur les problèmes les
origines du problème là où ils ont
refusé de mettre en place de mettre en
oeuvre des réformes faisable il préfère
qu'il n'y ait pas de réformes et que
rien ne se passe du tout en fin de
compte dont il est important de discuter
au sein du public sur à quoi
ressemblerait une mobile sans police il
est encore plus important en tout cas de
travailler sur des réformes profondes et
véritables qui pourrait changer les
stratégies policière
dès maintenant nous avons une liste de
44 réforme qui pourrait pourraient être
mises en oeuvre immédiatement et qui se
sont montrés par le passé comme étant
très efficace et capable de d'améliorer
la police il ne faut pas laisser nos
élus faire ce qu'il souhaite en disant
simplement qu'il faut abolir la police
ils n'ont rien fait ou montrant qu'il
souhaitait le faire par le passé n'ont
rien montré en matière de réformes
évidemment toute cette affaire
intervient on le sait dans un contexte
de campagne présidentielle
joe biden s'est exprimé aujourd'hui avec
cette déclaration assez forte
l'oeuvre de l'injustice raciale a sonné
quelle est votre réaction
très longtemps fait preuve de racisme il
a présenté des mesures qui augmentent et
les taux d'emprisonnement tour les
personnes noires des mesures racistes il
en a proposé dans de nombreux domaines
il a un passif très lourd en matière de
racisme nous ne lui faisons pas
confiance nous ne faisons pas confiance
à donald trump ne le faisons pas
confiance aux autres élus qui se
présentent comme des démocrates
progressistes
ce système on s'en sert à afin de
maintenir le statu quo et d'opprimer les
personnes de couleur c'est très
problématique
il faut donc réagir et changer les
choses merci des vikings d'avoir été
avec nous membres du conseil
d'administration des communautés unis
contre la brutalité policière en direct
donc de minneapolis les états unis qui
traverse donc une passe difficile colère
anti raciste on en parlait pandémie est
évidemment crise économique depuis le
début de la crise du corobin virus 43
millions d'américains se sont inscrits
au chômage le pib de la première
puissance économique mondiale a
également fuité de 5% voire du premier
trimestre 2009 un pour le bureau
national de recherche économique c est
bien une récession
le comité a conclu que la magnitude sans
précédents du déclin de l'emploi et de
la production et son étendue à
l'ensemble de l'économie mérite de
présenter cet épisode comme une
récession même si elles devaient
s'avérer plus courte que les
contractions précédentes l'épidémie de
cornas virus s'aggrave dans le monde
notamment en amérique du sud c'est ce
qu'a déclaré hier l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
pays le plus touché du continent le
brésil qui apporteront à mes sons
déconfinement stratégies différentes en
argentine au chili même au pérou qui
sont toujours confinés malgré les
difficultés pour la population à
respecter les mesures dans un contexte
économique dit
ici le franc soit et skavich jusqu'à 10
km de bouchons ce lundi matin à rio de
janeiro trois semaines que ce n'est pas
arrivé dans la ville carioca
la veille le maire marcelo krivets l'a
approuvé le redémarrage des activités
commerciales
car au brésil ce sont les autorités
locales qui prennent leurs propres
décisions sur le calendrier le processus
et des étapes de la reprise de
l'activité sociale terrain de football
bat restaurants et centres commerciaux
de l'état de rio de janeiro ont été
autorisés à rouvrir un déconfinement qui
pose question alors qu'avec près de
soixante dix mille cas la ville carioca
et sa région est l'une des plus touchées
par la pandémie au brésil
stratégies différentes en argentine où
le déconfinement du pays n'est pas
attendu avant le 28 juin
mais ce lundi soir joggeurs cyclistes
marcheurs et sportifs en tous genres ont
pu retrouver les rues de buenos aires s
après la levée des restrictions
concernant les activités physiques en
plein air il est temps de revenir devant
changer un peu des airs même sont
enfermés depuis plus de 70 jours je ne
sais pas combien de temps
80 jeux eux-mêmes et nous en avions
vraiment besoin en plein notre santé et
notre bien être aussi un confinement
débuté le 20 mars est particulièrement
stricte port du masque obligatoire dans
tous les espace public y compris la rue
demande de ne pas prendre les transports
en commun et nécessité d'un justificatif
pour sortir de son quartier cole
suspendu
des mesures qui ont permis au pays
d'être beaucoup moins touché que ses
voisins brésiliens et chiliens au chili
justement pays où le nombre d'infections
par million d'habitants est le plus
élevé au monde
la population est confinée depuis 11
semaines un confinement difficilement
maintenu par les autorités qui ont
décidé de renforcer les contrôles
policiers dans les quartiers de la
capitale chilienne
nous sommes en train d'effectuer une
mission dans le centre de santiago
parce que les gens ont été négligents
ils ont été responsables et nous avons
maintenant on semaine de quarantaine et
plus de 2000 morts un confinement devenu
également difficilement supportable pour
les péruviens deuxième pays le plus
touché du continent en quarantaine
depuis le 16 mars
le pérou a décidé de la prolonger
jusqu'au 30 juin soit le confinement le
plus long au monde
du lundi au samedi entre 21h et 4 heures
du matin et toute la journée du dimanche
la population doit rester chez elle
pourtant des millions de péruviens
continue de vendre des produits dans les
rues pour pouvoir survivre
une crise sanitaire qui se transforme en
crise économique
40% des péruviens ont perdu la totalité
de leur revenu
et pour évoquer la situation au brésil
nous sommes en direct avec house tahnoon
hardy journaliste indépendante bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir rustenhart dit merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes donc être sao paulo on
vient de le voir mais effectivement
toujours plus simple d'avoir quelqu'un
sur le terrain pour nous évoquer cette
situation comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui sur place dans une ville
comme são paulo et dans le reste du
brésil pense que je peux vous dire c'est
que la situation a évidemment ans de
plus en plus inquiétante
le brésil compte désormais plus de 700
cas confirmés du nouveau corps navires
us est presque quarante mille décès nous
sommes le deuxième pays le plus touché
le nombre de cas de contamination juste
derrière les états unis et le système de
santé au public brésilien qui était déjà
précaire est désormais aux bords de la
sihl saturation depuis plusieurs
semaines dans quelques états du nord du
pays en région amazonienne
mais même dans les grandes villes qui
étaient supposés être préparé à ce chaos
solitaire comme rio dé janeiro et ce en
parle où est ben même si le bilan
sanitaire s'alourdit et europe
énormément il ya une accélération
incomparable enfin nulle part au monde
la plupart des gouverneurs et des maires
des grandes villes ont décidé de
relâcher petit à petit le confinement et
l'ouverture par exemple de services non
essentiels ont été déjà annoncées ici à
san paolo
une ville qui est l'épicentre de la
maladie dans le pays
avec presque 200 mille personnes
contaminées il y attend le cas de san
paolo par exemple le confinement n'a
jamais été vraiment respecté comme par
un peu partout dans le brésil ici
désormais seulement 50% de la population
reste confinée chez elle
donc un bilan lourd pour résumer malgré
tout un déconfinement le non respect des
règles par la population est évidemment
tout comme dans d'autres pays d'ailleurs
un manque de masques et de tests oui
exactement le test de dépistage est un
vrai souci au brésil les chercheurs du
centre kovy de 19 bray
disent d'ailleurs les chiffres officiels
pour être jusqu'à 15 fois plus élevé
donc le brésil pourrait compter en verre
est en réalité entre 2 et 3 millions de
personnes contaminées mais ça on saura
jamais ce sont juste des estimations et
la chute de la popularité de bolton de
bolton arrow est une des conséquences de
sa gestion de son inaction face à cette
crise sanitaire
au début de la crise à peu près 50% de
brésiliens le soutenait contre seulement
30% de la population actuellement et
malgré l'épidémie dé plus en plus de
manifestations sont en train d'avoir
lieu des brésiliens qui en ont marre de
la gestion de bol solaro qui se lèvent
contre le racisme bien sûr mais surtout
pour défendre la démocratie brésilienne
qui selon eux est de plus en plus en
danger depuis menacé par le gouvernement
bolton a rouge est bon le président au
brésilien a reçu également de nombreuses
critiques de la part des responsables
sanitaires brésiliens qui ont reproché
la disparition du nombre de décès liés
au corps et 19 du site internet officiel
du ministère de la santé
il ya quelques jours c'était vendredi
dernier bon ces chiffres ont réapparu
quelques heures plus tard mais depuis
vendredi les autorités comptabilise plus
que les pc survécu pardon survenus ces
dernières 24 heures elle n'y ajoute plus
les tests rélévé positif des patients
décédés les jours précédents donc il ya
de nombreuses critiques qui apparaissent
et du corps médical mais aussi de la
classe politique brésilienne aurait
aussi dans la population
alors il faut dire un outre cette
affaire de chiffres que j'aille rôle son
arôme voulait plus publiés
semblerait que le président brésilien
fasse pression notamment sur les
gouverneurs des régions justement pour
des cons fine et on imagine les
conséquences dramatiques que cela peut
avoir
oui exactement c'est déjà le cas des
gouverneurs comme celui de san paolo où
de rio de janeiro qui avait engagé au
début de la pic de l'épidémie
un bras de fer contre le président jiang
olson a roué qui avait impliqué de
mesures de confinement sont quatre ans
de relâcher et cela est très inquiétant
selon une étude d'ailleurs public et par
l'université de washington le brésil
pourrait compter à presque 200 mille
morts par le nouveau coronavirus
jusqu'au mois d'août un pouvoir
atteindre jusqu'à 5000 décès par jour
mais selon le responsable de cette
recherche américaine les chiffres pour
être encore plus élevé aussi les loups
gouvernement et la population à brésil
et ne prennent pas cette crise au
sérieux et si le losc darleux n'est pas
instauré pendant au moins deux semaines
mais ce scénario semble pas du tout
envisageable serait en train de voir
exactement le contraire
le confinement est de moins en moins
respectée par la population et les
services non essentiels comme des salles
de sport ou alors des banques ou des
agences immobilières commencent à
rouvrir leurs portes un peu partout dans
le pays et ce qui est très
contradictoire parce que la courbe de
cas de contamination et de décès ne
cesse de monter merci au stade mardi
d'avoir été avec nous avons exposé cette
situation inquiétante au brésil et c'est
le premier pays occidental qui ne compte
plus aucun cap coronavirus la nouvelle
zélande s'est félicité hier de la
guérison du dernier patient et aucun
autre cas n'a été recensé le pays relève
donc les mesures de restriction de quoi
réjouir la population les explications
de solenn gaudin aucune contamination
depuis 17 jours en nouvelle-zélande
conséquence la levée des mesures de
restriction dès ce mardi dans tout le
pays annonce lundi de la première
ministre salue et mondialement pour son
leadership pendant cette crise yacine
dardenne reste prudente
j'ai pu annoncer que le gouvernement a
convenu que nous passons
maintenant au niveau 1 pour que notre
économie est à nouveau complètement
ouverte
nous sommes convaincus que nous avons
éliminé la transmission du virus en
nouvelle zélande pour l'instant mais
l'élimination n'est pas un point dans le
temps c'est un effort soutenu
nous verrons certainement des cas ici
encore c'est la raison pour laquelle nos
frontières est notre première ligne de
défense
car nous visons à ne pas importer le
virus plus de distanciation sociale ou
d'interdiction de se rassembler dès ce
mardi matin les néo-zélandais ont repris
leurs habitudes de vie des citoyens
visiblement satisfait de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
nous en sommes tous assez satisfait je
pense que nous avons vraiment bien
réussi en tant que pays à nous
débarrasser de tout cela eh oui je suis
vraiment heureux que nous soyons au
niveau 1
nous voyons certainement beaucoup plus
de monde qu'à la même heure la semaine
dernière est certainement plus qui hier
également ce qui est vraiment excitant
pour nous c'est formidable de retrouver
un sentiment de normalité
fondamentalement pouvoir être dans un
café et retrouver des amis
le confinement et les gestes barrières
étaient mises en place depuis le 25 mars
en plus de ces précautions le
gouvernement avait lancé une vaste
campagne de dépistage plus de 260 mille
tests ont été pratiqués sur la
population
en tout depuis le début de la pandémie
le pays a enregistré un millier de cas
et déplore seulement 22 morts
on est resté avec mon dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur les
violences policières et le racisme n'est
pas un débat a ravivé en france après le
décès de georges floyd aux états unis
edouard philippe appelle au respect à la
confiance mais aussi l exigence
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre et puis
nous parlerons de la réponse de la
justice dans cette affaire justement de
violences policières présumées la
manifestation de la vérité peut-elle
prix y ont fait un bond des rangements
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
date à ce trop fine il ya un tournant
mais on re se remet à vivre mais dans
une autre direction c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire de l'humanité que
pour sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais fait d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
quelle valeur on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura l'inde et baltique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne au profit
de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président entrant pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième garde
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
l'afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'hérault pour les
états unis quelle stratégie vous avez
déployés dans le sud kivu pour limiter
la propagation du virus on a proposé à
ce qu'est le confinement puisse être
sélectif est concerné seulement des
personnes âgées à haut risque de
complication pour sensibiliser la
population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisque on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
j'étais si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et coronavirus ça pourrait être
très très difficile pour nous
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vos jouets
à lévis mais quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils n'étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques des matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment est
ce qu'elles peuvent transformer après la
pandémie la crise maintenant à fait bien
comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier des
banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle ne part pas seulement d'elle même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de nos activités ou les billetteries
sont à l'arrêt l'impact financier est
énorme
ce sera des matches sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des fluxs
que nous attendons c'est effectivement
la possibilité de rouvrir sans ces
mesures barrières le plus vite possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché cela
prendra plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 9
juin
nouveau rassemblement est un hommage ce
soir dans l'hexagone vont saluer la
mémoire de georges floyd et combattre le
racisme dans la police notamment
elle place de la république à paris
edouard philippe lui appelle au respect
à la confiance mais aussi à l'exigence
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre
lendemain des mesures dévoilées par son
ministre de l'intérieur
cette gestion de la crise sanitaire en
france sur le gris une enquête
préliminaire a été ouverte par le
procureur de la république de paris
depuis le 24 mars dernier l'a reçu 62
plaint à son signalement l'enquète
portent notamment sur la mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui et non assistance à
personne en péril
et on en parlait cet hommage français au
moment où se sont déroulées les
funérailles de djordje floyd dans
l'intimité à houston ils étaient
également venus nombreux se recueillir
en sa mémoire dans sa ville natale
depuis la mort de cet homme
afro-américains asphyxié par un policier
le 25 mai des appels à réformer la
police se multiplient partout aux états
unis ce qui fragilise la campagne de
donald trump au profit de son rival joe
biden
[Musique]
paris lille grenoble dijon ou encore à
me après les mobilisations de la semaine
dernière nouveau rassemblement donc et
hommage dans plusieurs villes de france
est le rendez vous était fixé à 18h pile
à paris place de la république à l'heure
précise à laquelle ont débuté les
obsèques de georges klein et de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique
plusieurs syndicats partis politiques
organisations étudiantes ou lg se sont
associés à l'appel à manifester lancé
par sos racisme pour combattre le
racisme dans la police
dans ce contexte donné de dénonciation
des violences policières le gouvernement
affiche sa mobilisation
un mot d'ordre depuis hier tolérance
zéro contre le racisme
edouard philippe et christophe castaner
était à evry à la rencontre des
policiers qui travaillent dans les
quartiers difficiles
le premier ministre reconnaît une
émotion très grande très légitime est
très partagée vis-à-vis des violences
policières
je suis en essonne dans un département
ou à de nombreuses reprises les forces
de l'ordre des gardiens de la paix ont
été victimes d'attaqués physiques terry
gardiens de la paix les forces de
l'ordre qui assure notre protection
nous leur devons respect et confiance
l'immense majorité des français a
vis-à-vis de nos forces de l'ordre de
nos gardiens de la paix respect et
confiance
et parce que nous devons avoir respect
et confiance avait femmes et des hommes
qui s'engagent dans des missions
redoutablement difficile est essentielle
nous avons également un devoir
d'exigence vis-à-vis d'elle il a dit la
vérité c'est que le racisme est une une
forme de maladie de l'âme une forme de
faiblesse
il faut savoir que nous devons tous être
à la hauteur des principes de la
république
en étant exigeant vis-à-vis de ce qu'ils
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
comme en étant exigeant vis-à-vis de
soi-même les méthodes d' arrestations
policières de plus en plus décrié c'est
christophe castaner a annoncé l'abandon
de la technique dite de l'étranglement
hier lors d'une conférence de presse
qu'en est-il de celle du placage
ventrale c'est la question que pose la
famille d'éric show via au ministre de
l'intérieur dans une lettre publiée hier
cet homme de 42 ans est mort en janvier
dernier après un maintien au sol par des
policiers lors d'un contrôle d'identité
musclés une position qui empêchent de
respirer correctement selon les ong
amnesty international et selon un
dernier rapport elle serait aussi
responsable de la mort d'adama traoré la
famille des riches ou bien réclame
l'interdiction est donc de cette méthode
ce matin l'avocat est revenu sur les
annonces de christophe castaner ne sont
pas suffisantes car elles sont
singulières et n'entraîne pas de
stratégie globale s'agissant de
violences policières
il ya à la fois une impunité une
augmentation concernant ces recours à la
force
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christian chou via perdent cédric
souvient à décéder donc on le disait le
5 janvier dernier d'une asphyxie deux
jours après son interpellation sur le
quai branly dans le 7e arrondissement de
la capitale bonsoir creissan devient
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on imagine que
cette affaire giorgio floyd à a ravivé
chez vous de douloureux souvenirs les
similitudes sont bien là selon vous oui
yahia wauquiez il est mort il est mort
par asphyxie e cédric mans par un succès
donc c'est la même morts ils ont été
tous les deux comme en bas a condamné
condamné à mort après un contrôle de
police
la peine de mort a été abolie en france
et aujourd'hui les gardiennes d'apple le
droit de donner la peine de mort elle
s'est seulement christ afin qu'un
salaire a notamment annoncé la fin de
cette technique un de l'étranglement
c'est une vraie victoire c'est ce que
vous attendez depuis longtemps non c'est
pas une vraie victoire chez un tout
petit filet parce que le plaquage contre
allée aussi dangereux quand vous avez
deux trois gars sur votre dos tu penses
que le tome 1 des ça peut faire deux à
trois cents kilos vous avez ça sur le
dos vous avez le ventre meurtri j'avais
tout cas toute la chaîne de commandeur
respiratoires qu'est qui est
complètement bloqué donc aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire que c'est une victoire
voilà bien un pack été fait mais c'est
un effet d'annoncé c'est tout tout ce
qui a été promis
il ya cinq mois
on l'a demandé on n'a pas reçu un seul
courrier on n'a pas reçu les avocats n'a
pas été mis en rapport
c'est nous qui avons bien qu a vomi
légende a pas aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe justement aux états unis qui
semblent aussi créé une telle prise de
conscience une vraie colère en france
avec ses manifestations
c'est un vrai espoir dans votre combat
va se font bien la preuve c'est que
aujourd'hui ça a réveillé les grandes
instances notre président s'est
manifestée parce qu'on n'avait rien
après jusqu'à présent et ce week-end lui
la sphère de charge
comment aux états unis il a compris
qu'il a compris qu'il y avait un vrai
problème
il fallait faire quelque chose et d'ascq
où on sort du chapeau
on va arrêter le lac et des tremblements
ça sera déjà une bonne chose ça va les
calmer
la famille se souvient n'est pas calmé
la famille traoré l'epa cad
comme à manacor elle n'est pas calmé on
nous errons lui donne des miettes
donc voila moi je suis pas d'accord avec
tout ce qui a été dit j'ai croisé de se
castagner ce matin je lui ai dit en face
entre quatre yeux ce que je pensais et
il m'a même dit vous ne m'en voulez un
petit peu aujourd'hui
en ce moment vous avez un petit peu
après moi je dis jamais pas appel à la
ministre voit la différence
pourtant ce mini christian souvient on
comprend évidemment votre émotion à
votre colère mais c'est plutôt rare
qu'un ministre de l'intérieur voilà
reconnaissent un problème de racisme au
sein de de la police y en a même qui
accuse ans ce ministre notamment au
rassemblement national de lâcher ses
troupes
c'est quand même un début pour vous même
s'il n'est pas suffisant oui alors si ça
fait plaisir à tout le monde certes mais
c'est qu'un début mais pour moi c'est un
feu de paille
c'est yves il se passe rien derrière on
a demandé comment qu'il devait faire des
préparations père des études
aujourd'hui on vous contrôle pour un
contrôle d'identité pour une infraction
au code de la route si elle en actions
ce qui est pas le cas en plus puisque
l'encontre de le démontrer qu'il ya eu
infraction
amiens b b il a donné ses papiers il a
été il était il a été un en règle et là
d'un seul coup la salle on vous dit ah
ben il est mort il est pas mort le 5
janvier malade il est mort le 3 janvier
sur le pavé au pied de la tour eiffel
ça c'est une réalité il est rentré on
l'a mis dans le samu qu'il était
cliniquement mort ont l'art qu'on paie
pour être à faire démarrer son coeur qui
pour qu' il soit disant humeur de joie
après mais c'était déjà fini
aujourd'hui clairement oui la liaison
était coupée quelques instants
aujourd'hui clairement qu'est ce que
vous attendez de la justice vous avez
souvent dit que voilà vous ne voulez pas
la profession entière mais mais à ces
quatre individus ans qui ont interpellé
votre fils qu'est ce que vous attendez
90 mais tueur d'enfant et huard de pair
les tueurs d'hommes de maris
j'en veux à tous ces gens là qui qui
aujourd'hui ont pas scrupules ils
arrivent à enlever la vie' aujourd'hui
d'un travailleur qui est en plein
travail pour un contrôle d'identité ou à
contrôler de jeu c'est parce qu'ils ont
un hôtel comment qui ont prétexté le
téléphone il a dit qu'il avait un
téléphone un casque avec après décroché
sa plaque d'immatriculation n'étaient
pas sa vérité luttera visite puisque on
a des photos on a tout ce qu'il faut
donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est un assassinat c'est un
mur je sais que les avocats ils n'aiment
pas que j'en parle moi ceci n'a mais là
je parle de mon fils cédric joue bien
voilà on a tué cédric joue bien sur le
pavé au pied de la tour eiffel
donc voilà est aujourd'hui un problème
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de vidéos
il ya beaucoup de vidéos de l'instant où
ça s'est passé et de la scène voilà
aujourd'hui le ministre a évoqué
effectivement hier en tout cas là la
réforme de l'igpn la police des polices
c'est un début
là aussi plus d'indépendance de cette
police des polices avec peut-être moins
d'impunité du coup je pense parce que la
police des polices aujourd'hui année
police pour régler les problèmes de la
police
donc ça fait un peu ambigu par contre si
vous mettez une police complètement
extérieur un organisme complètement
extérieur pour savoir ce qui se passe
dans la police
peut-être qu'il y aura des meilleurs
contrôles et des meilleurs c'est fait
moi je peux vous donner une situation ma
belle fille quant à nightend chez pn à
la fin un accord entre elle a été
entendue deux heures ou une heure ou
deux heures jeudi pu et on lui a dit
vous savez vous avez plus de facilité
que nous pour faire des investigations
vous veillez à dix à la femme à qui on
vient de tuer le mari et c'est eux qui
le disent on a plus de facilité à faire
des investigations
oui j'ai à nouveau présentés dans les
commissariats mener nos enquêtes dire
aux gens vous êtes des menteurs pas des
mots cas c'est un gag sagan l'igpn de
moyens volonté d'implanter c'est la
volonté d' impunité parce qu'on peut
passer vers la police tient alors dans
le temps la place à une bavure
maintenant on appelle ça du du racisme
on appelle ça avait des commandes de dae
des violences policières
on appelle ça fait avant c'est une
bavure alors c'était le nom était fort
aujourd'hui c'est des violences
policières
mais les violences policières
aujourd'hui elles existent elles sont
pas faites par tous les policiers
ça c'est à fait certain on n'en veut pas
toutes les polices de france on n'a pas
de haine contre la police aparicio via
toute la famille joueur n'a pas de haine
contre la police moi j'ai de la haine on
aden entre ces quatre individus qui nous
ont eu une vie notre la vie de notre
enfant de notes du père du mari du frère
c'est atroce vie aujourd'hui
cinq mois après on est comme au premier
jour quand le petit qu'à quatre ans le
petit dernier à 4 en équipe
je veux voir mon papa au cimetière qui
se voulait raconter quand il est dans la
tombe
c'est un vrai problème aujourd'hui sari
problème tout ça parce que ya quatre
individus ont décidé un beau jour de
faire un contrôle et d'aller au bout de
leur contrôle
sont pas arrêtés mesrine des screen est
déjà enterré ils ont pas arrêté
non ils ont arrêté un pauvre qui possède
voilà travailleurs qui rame qui
travaillait pour nourrir 5 enfants et
travailler et sa femme
et voilà donc aujourd'hui je peux pas
accepter ça on peut pas accepter ça
honteux pas que c'était sa merci
christian souvient en tout cas votre
témoignage en direct sur rt france merci
à vous et dans la lignée de la demande
du gouvernement emmanuel macron aurait
demandé sollicités nicole belloubet pour
se pencher un peu plus sur la sphère
adama traoré on en parlait c'est ce que
croient savoir nos confrères de l'agencé
france presse la ministre de la justice
a donc voulu inviter est proche d'adama
traoré à le rencontrer pour échanger
mais la famille du jeune homme mort en
2016 au cours d'une interpellation lui
adressent aux fins de non recevoir a dit
attendre des avancées judiciaire et non
des invitations à la discussion qui
n'auraient aucune finalité procédurale
l'avocat de la famille met également en
avant la séparation des pouvoirs la
justice et a laissé les deux témoins que
nous demandons depuis quatre ans les
témoins que nous demandons à être
entendu les témoins principaux dans la
mort de mon petit frère
une femme et l'homme qui était dans
l'appartement
ça fait quatre ans que nous demandons à
la justice que la justice refuse à
refuser faut savoir que notre avocat
maître yassine bouzrou a demandé
plusieurs actes est quasiment à chaque
fois tous les actes sont refusés donc
aujourd'hui un rapport de force a été
installé une petite victoire
sauf que c'est pas une petite victoire
que nous voulons hier le président s'est
exprimé à demander à ce que le ministre
de la justice puisse se saisir de la
sphère d'adama traoré le ministre de la
justice a contacté notre avocat me
yassine bouzrou pour nous rencontrer
sauf qu'aujourd'hui le ministre de la
justice ne doit pas rencontrer la
famille traoré
mais le ministre de la justice doit
rencontrer le procureur on rappelle que
la séparation entre l'état et la justice
on ne demande pas à ce que les
discussions se fassent dans un salon de
thé
l'elysée on demande que des actes
judiciaires soient fait face aux
affaires de violences policières alors
que les procédures sont souvent longues
la justice peut-elle être efficace
peut-elle faire triompher la vérité
pour en parler nous sommes avec
christian saint-palais avocat président
de l'association des avocats pénalistes
bonsoir à vous m merci d'être avec nous
à ses côtés marc lifshitz secrétaire
général adjoint unités magistrats sm fo
premier vice procureur au tgi de
pontoise bonsoir à vous également merci
d'être en direct on a entendu ses cris 1
tout d'abord le perdent c'est vrai que
je trouve ya et puis elle a third adama
traoré pour vous la justice doit
véritablement entendre ses cris
aujourd'hui on commence par vous marquez
nif quitte la justice écoute bien
entendu la justice vis au coeur de la
cité et donc la justice entend un bien
entendu mais il faut quand même replacer
les choses dans le l'ordre juridique
normale quand la third adama traoré est
dit que la ministre n'a pas à rencontrer
la famille
nous sommes d'accord bien entendu car il
s'agit d'un coup de couteau d'une
entorse à la règle de la séparation des
pouvoirs
mais quand elle dit
la milice devraient rencontrer le
procureur pas plus pas plus il faut que
la justice puisse faire son travail dans
la sérénité et la ministre est et qui
que ce soit n'a pas à s'ingérer dans le
fonctionnement la justice
en revanche là où il ya une vraie
responsabilité de l'exécutif sait qu'il
faut donner à la justice les moyens de
travailler or aujourd'hui manifestement
ce n'est pas le cas christian
saint-palais la jeunesse aujourd'hui n'a
pas les moyens de travailler vous êtes
d'accord ça c'est un problème bien plus
vaste encore que celui du traitement des
violences policières
oui ça je ne
je rejoins monsieur le procureur sur ce
constat la justice manque de moyens
et concernant les violences policières
il ya autre chose quand même
ce que nous entendons la dent dans les
deux affaires que vous avez évoqué c'est
le ressenti de deux familles de victimes
de parties civiles dont aucun et qui ont
le sentiment que la justice ne répond
pas à leurs attentes
alors ça ça n'est pas parce qu'une
partie a le sentiment que la justice ne
répond pas à ce n'attendent que ça
signifie forcément que la justice serait
mal rendue attention à l'interprétation
des choses mais je dois dire quand même
que en matière de violences policières
c'est un sentiment il faut le dire
souvent partagée de ce que la justice
n'entendrait pas suffisamment ceux qui
expriment des doléances à l'égard du
traitement qui leur a été réservé par
les policiers alors il ya sans doute une
certaine solidarité qui a existé que
l'on peut comprendre les policiers
exercent une force qui peut être
légitime
les policiers remplissent des missions
difficiles et on peut comprendre aussi
que dans l'exercice de ses missions et
des erreurs soient commises ou des actes
non adaptés et été réalisés ce qui
déçoit euros c'est la difficulté qu'il
ya lorsque des plaintes sont déposées
que ce soit par l'igpn est parfois par
les magistrats
downtown ce qui est dénoncé oui il
existe des violences policières
cela existe il est normal que ceux qui
sont mises en cause dans ces procédures
se défendent et s'explique
mais il faut offrir une réponse
judiciaire rapide à ceux qui s'en
plaignent
il y va de la crédibilité de l'autorité
de la police et donc de la justice aussi
marqueurs lifting c'est vrai que c'est
une critique qui revient souvent c'est
ce que nous disait par exemple notre
invité va les rendre saint-just tout à
l'heure qui lui même aucun sauf erreur
de ma part l'année souci c'est que c'est
vrai que voilà il ya un temps judiciaire
qui est très long et qui s'aiment
confusion quand vous voyez que dans
cette affaire d'âme à traoré il ya deux
expertises qui incriminent les forces de
l'ordre une troisième indépendante qui
dit ballon
la verte pardon qui disculpent un les
forces de l'ordre et la troisième qui
incrimine justement ces forces de
l'ordre nouvelle expertise indépendante
demandée par la famille c'est vrai que
ça sème la confusion forcément et
suscite la colère
alors je ne rentrerai pas sur le fond du
dossier pour la raison principale c'est
que je ne le connais pas et vous savez
qu'un dossier d'instruction c'est
quelque chose qui est couvert par le
secret de l'instruction article 11 du
code de procédure pénale et donc je ne
dirais pas sûr évidemment pas de réagir
sur le fond du dossier mais c'est vrai
que c'est un nid lustration c'est une
affaire qui suscite la la colère et on
comprend pourquoi plusieurs expertises
la longueur alors il est certain que la
justice doit elle plus diligente et
c'est là où on retrouve le la
problématique des moyens très
concrètement ça veut dire que un juge
d'instruction il a beaucoup de dossiers
souvent plus de 150 avec un nombre
important de détenus des affaires par
définition qui sont graves mais souvent
aussi complexe et c'est vous dire que
c'est les moyens pour travailler sont
très limités ensuite quand il lance des
commissions rogatoires
eh bien ça dépend de du nombre des
policiers et des enquêteurs qui vont
travailler sur cette commission
rogatoire
et tout cela prend énormément de temps
un temps effectivement judiciaire très
long qui ne correspond pas avec les
attentes les attentes du public
on le comprend et si on veut une justice
de meilleure qualité il ne faut surtout
pas supprimer l'instruction
le syndicat représente et pour le
maintien du juge d'instruction mais il
faut absolument lui donner les moyens de
travailler
alors les moyens évidemment il ya aussi
m christian saint palais ce sentiment
d'impunité qui revient souvent dans les
débats aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est
dénoncé actuellement dans la rue vous
êtes d'accord c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui en france
ce sentiment d'impunité des policiers ne
seraient pas sanctionnés
vrai ou faux je me méfie de ce genre
d'affirmation mais si vous me parlez de
sentiments alors oui je dirai que ce
sentiment est très partagé mais même
dans les audiences vous avez assez
simple où ce qu'ils comparaissent devant
les tribunaux se plaignent de la façon
dont on leur a parlé de la façon dont on
les a interpellés avec une force qui
disent souvent non nécessaire et vous
savez que c'est un propos qui est assez
souvent balayer d'abord parce que les
juges doivent aller vite pour traiter
certaines affaires contrairement à ce
que nous disait en tout à l'heure il ya
des affaires qui sont jugés
immédiatement et je vous assure que ce
qu'ils comparaissent devant leurs juges
et qui ont le sentiment que les
doléances qu'ils expriment les critiques
qu'ils formulent contre les policiers et
qu'il formule de bonne foi souvent quand
ils ont le sentiment qu'elles sont
méprisés ses doléances
eh bien ça crée un sentiment de rupture
avec la police dans un premier temps
parce qu'ils se disent mais enfin la
police ne m'a pas traité comme elle le
devait comme devrait le faire une police
républicaine
et puis c'est une déception est donc
l'éloignement de la justice qui ne prend
pas le temps soit parce qu'elle n'a pas
dans le jeu je le dis tu as forcément le
contraire mais qui ne prend pas le temps
en temps alors ce sentiment d'impunité
il n'est de tout cela oui je suis
persuadé qu'il ya des violences
policières qui restent impunis je redis
qu'il est nécessaire que ceux qui sont
mises en cause puisse se défendre et
dans les affaires donc parlons sur le
terrain médiatique
moi non plus je ne sais rien de cette
affaire l'avocat des familles expriment
ce qu'il a à dire et les mises en cause
doivent se défendre il faut les faire
bénéficier eux aussi de la présomption
d'innocence mais largement d'une manière
générale il ya un sentiment
effectivement de l'unité de non écoute
en tout cas de ceux qui se plaignent de
la façon dont ils sont traités alors qu
on nous répond le magistrat sur ce
sentiment d'impunité trois choses sur le
sentiment d'impunité qui seraient
couverts par les magistrats je m'inscris
en faux
nous sommes des praticiens du droit au
quotidien nous entendons des personnes
interpellées nous dirigeons des enquêtes
donc nous savons très bien les services
qui dérape
nous savons très bien les dérives
individuelles et nous savons aussi
enquêter dessus est sanctionné et exiger
des sanctions
aujourd'hui les affaires qui provoque
l'émotion sont des affaires très
médiatisées mais vous avez un certain
nombre de policiers et de gendarmes une
ultra minorité bien entendu qui qui
franchissent la ligne jaune
quelquefois d'ailleurs par un mauvaise
encadrement ou alors couverts par
l'encadrement et ils sont sanctionnés
sauf que on le sait que trop peu mais
ils sont sanctionnés régulièrement par
les tribunaux on ne va pas contester
qu'il peut y avoir une difficulté dans
les rapports de la police et de la
population et je crois qu'il faut un
petit peu élevé le débat on a une
difficulté d'abord de ces deux zones de
non-droit dans lesquelles la police n'a
plus le droit de cité
et si vous n'intervenez pas en force les
policiers sont prises à partie ça c'est
une réalité
c'est à dire que la république s'est
retiré de quartiers en difficulté et
aujourd'hui on en paye le prix
et puis vous avez aussi des policiers
sortant d'école des jeunes policiers qui
ne sont pas encadrés par des gens qui
ont l'expérience qu'ils ont finalement
poursuivre leur carrière dans des
endroits moins chaud entre guillemets eh
bien nous avons des bleus en première
ligne inexpérimentée qui viennent
travailler la boule au ventre
ça aussi c'est une réalité mais je ne
contesterai pas mon l'organisation je
représente ne conteste pas qu'il ya un
besoin de formation des policiers
et on a un besoin d'encadrement et pour
cela il faut qu'ils aient des policiers
d'expérience qui encadrent les jeunes
policiers qui opère par exemple dans
l'aide dans les banlieue nord de paris
boudé les banlieues nord de marseille et
puis après il faut du contrôle et de la
sanction
à l'aide d'un canot des ronds
logique il faut peut-être revoir
justement là vous parlez de travail des
policiers sur sur le terrain mais c'est
vrai que la justice voilà c'est tout le
problème avec cette question de
l'impunité la manifeste les
manifestations de gilet jaune ont
notamment pour le moins écorné l'image
de la police
il ya eu huit enquêtes 1 qui ont
justifié l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire mais m saint-palais aucun
policier suspendu c'est ce genre de
bilan qui peuvent créer la colère selon
vous justement sur si vous saviez le
nombre de deux jeunes de 18 ans 20 ans
qui ont participé à ces manifestations
de gilet jaune et d'autres citoyens
d'ailleurs et qui voulaient exprimer
leur appartenance à la république en
défilant et en exprimant des
revendications de citoyens si vous
saviez le nombre de ceux que nous avons
accompagné devant les tribunaux
poursuivi qu'il se tenait parfois pour
des jets de projectiles avéré pas une
ciné mais qu'ils avaient été victimes de
tirs avec la fesse complètement marché
par un tir de svt
on s'est habitué à ce qu'il faut bien
appeler des violences et des jeunes et
qui découvre la vie citoyenne en
participant à des manifestations il faut
prouver que c'est assez quand même
magnifique que des jeunes traînent tu
tombes pour s'exprimer dans la rue dans
le cadre de manifestations autorisées et
qui sont victimes de ces violences la
voyez ça c'est ce qui crée la rupture
avec avec nos services de police et je
pense que effectivement monsieur vos
coeurs disais tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait un problème de formation c'est
évident mais il ya un problème aussi il
faut mettre les murs sur les choses il y
à des violences policières
il faut que conte le ghz et il faut dire
qu'ensuite les procédures seront menées
puis il faudra aller jusqu'au bout et
ont pris jusqu'à des suspensions après
qu'ils se sont détendus dans le cadre
des procédures disciplinaires et il faut
arrêter avec le fait de doter d'armes
qui sont tout de même des armes de
violence les policiers qui encadre les
expressions des citoyens l'objet d'un
autre débat en tout cas merci à tous les
deux ans christian saint palais
et marc lifted sein secrétaire général
adjoint unités magistrats snm est fou
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons en
france avec l'ouverture par le parquet
de paris d'une vaste enquête sur la
gestion des crises du cordat virus elles
visent notamment à les chefs d'homicides
involontaires with en danger de la vie
d'autrui d'autrui puis à direction les
états unis où se déroulent les obsèques
de georges de floride
[Musique]
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
autre
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france 21h30 heure de
paris le bilan du coronavirus dans
l'hexagone le nombre de personnes en
réanimation continue de baisser avec
moins de 1000 malades selon la direction
générale de la santé la france a
enregistré 87 morts liés au cog hill 19
dans les hôpitaux ces dernières 24
heures au total 29 1296 personnes sont
mortes depuis le début de l'épidémie et
nous venons d'apprendre que angela
merkel et emmanuel macron pressés tout
même l'union européenne dans une lettre
de se préparer à une prochaine pandémie
une gestion de crise en tout cas au
coeur des tribunaux le parquet de paris
a ouvert une vaste enquête préliminaire
sur la gestion de la crise lié aux
coronavirus particulier syndicats ou
encore associations mettent en cause
notamment plusieurs départements
ministériels et responsables
administratifs les explications en
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
l enquête pénale n'est pas là pour
définir des responsabilités politiques
ou administratives
mais pour mettre au jour d'éventuelles
infractions pénales s'il y a des fautes
pénales se seront très probablement
c'est une hypothèse d faute non
intentionnelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
laurence bouquet fixe présidente du
collectif inter blog dont soir florence
bouquet merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france vous faites partie de
ces collectifs qui ont déposé des
plaintes notamment sur les masques
aujourd'hui cette ouverture d' enquête
c'est un bon début pour vous oui tout à
fait parce qu'on voulait se faire
entendre de mettre à jour le manquement
qu'il y a eu tout au long de cette
gestion du coc vide et c'était important
qu'on se représente est entendue
aujourd'hui quels sont les principaux
griefs justement vous reprocher au
gouvernement dans la gestion de cette
crise qu'est ce qui justifie justement
quel qu'il soit obligé de répondre de
ses fautes notamment non ce qu'on se
positionne par rapport aux masques ffp2
parce que au bloc opératoire il ya une
partie de l'équipe
c'est à dire l'équipe anesthésique qui
portent des masques ffp2 et l'équipe
genre j call qui en est dépourvu sur
beaucoup d'établissements donc c'est un
bon ami m en a mandaté m division qui a
écouté nos d'élégance et qui a mis les
établissements en demeure de nous
fournir à l'équipe chirurgicale des
masques ffp2 il ya clairement eu
préjudice racontez-nous justement cette
époque parce que souvent quand on porte
plainte c'est qu'il ya clairement un
préjudice
de nombreux soignants on imagine son
sont tombés malades cette époque là bien
sûr il ya des soignants qui ont été
contaminés est le fait surtout que alors
comme on dit c'est michel jouets qu'ils
s à l'absence de preuve n'est pas preuve
de l'absence
on a pas de consensus scientifique qui
va dire que le virus est présent dans
les fumées chirurgicale mais toujours
est il que il y à des risques pour le
personnel et de l'instant où il ya des
risques des établissements se doivent
d'après le code du travail de de fournir
des précautions pour prévenir ces
risques c'est d'assurer la sécurité des
soignants donc c'était important de tous
les soignants sont équipés enceinte de
de masque chirurgical alors clairement
l'anc est un vise les chefs de mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui d'homicides et
blessures involontaires de
non-assistance à personnes en péril les
mots sont forts d'ailleurs le procureur
de la république a précisé qu'il n'était
pas là pour définir des responsabilités
politiques ou administratives mais bel
et bien pour mettre à jour des
infractions pénales des décideurs
nationaux pour vous clairement un
ministre aujourd'hui doit être
considérée comme pénalement responsable
facettes
face à cette justement pénurie de
masques alors je pense que au vu de ce
qui a été dit par rapport à la
gouvernance où il ya eu un peu tout a
été dit et le au contraire également je
pense qu'ils doivent aussi assumer une
part de responsabilité effectivement
vous pardonnez moi je vous ai coupé en
tranches vous en prie non je disais une
part de responsabilité mais mais c'est
vrai que cette crise a révélé beaucoup
de de lourdeur de l'administration
française c'est ce qui est vraiment
ressorti à différents étages
est ce que ce n'est pas juste je me fais
volontairement l'avocat du diable mais
et voilà de poursuivre une seule
personne un ministre qui finalement est
dans un système très lourd
il endosse et pas le ministre celle des
établissements de santé qui ont été
visés par cette plainte
les ministres sont aussi visés en
l'occurrence pour leur mauvaise gestion
de la crise
pénalement oui sur d'autres malawi ville
sur sur d'autres plaintes effectivement
il ya eu 80 plein qui me semble au total
qui ont été déposés clairement
qu'attendez-vous de de cette enquête
aujourd'hui nous ce qu'on voudrait faire
c'est faire remonter toutes les toute la
défaillance qui a eu par rapport à notre
gouvernance en fait on a un système d'
entité décisionnel qui a dit qui a dit
et qui a fait aussi un peu n'importe
quoi est ce qu'on concernant le matériel
on l'a bien vu avec donc notamment les
les masses le gel les sur blues
qu'est-ce qu'on a eu d'autres également
on a eu par rapport au respirateur aussi
il ya eu d énormément de deux
respirateurs qui ont été commandés et
qui en fait n'était pas du tout adaptée
pour le les patients à la prise en
charge des patients qu'aux vides il y a
eu toutes ces transport de patients au
csa a été fait par les hélicoptères les
comment le le porte hélicoptères
tonnerre tout cela engendrait beaucoup
de frais et c'était pas en fait
justifiée il y avait des établissements
privés qui étaient beaucoup plus près
que les 800 kilomètres qui ont été
nécessaires pour transférer des patients
de de mulhouse à toulouse et je pense
que voilà il ya une gestion qui a été
désastreuse alors aujourd'hui angela
merkel emmanuel macron presse l'union
européenne de se préparer une prochaine
pandémie c'est ce qu'on vient
d'apprendre
ils ont adressé une lettre à l'union
européenne estimant que l'union
européenne n'avait pas été à la hauteur
face au co vide
19 il évoque éventuellement une
prochaine pandémie
hypothétique vous êtes en accord avec ça
parce que au-delà de la france l'europe
n'a pas su faire face selon vous
également
oui pour beaucoup de choses c'est vrai
qu'on a on a fermé les usines on les a
transférés en chine un peu enfin petit
peu partout et la problématique c'est
qu'on n'est plus en capacité d'avoir
rapidement du matériel
heureusement qu'il ya eu le système d
qui s'est mis en place où les personnels
soignants ont posté ont mis ont fait
appel
que ce soit aux entreprises de btp au
parfumerie
il ya eu une vraie cohésion de la part
de l'ensemble du public soit de nos
gouvernants pour pour se substituer
justement à ce défaut de cette
défaillance en tout même au niveau
humain on l'a bien vu
les îles ont rappelé des élèves
infirmiers qui ne sont pas formés alors
qu'elle a dans la réserve sanitaire il y
a à peu près 4000 donc pour moi je suis
un script 4000 personnel soignant et qui
n'ont pas du tout été dispatchés sur les
les endroits où il y avait nécessité
d'avoir des personnes qui étaient formés
en plus mettre des élèves qui sont pas
formés ces mots domicile merci beaucoup
florence a moqué vice-présidente du
collectif interlope d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france dans une
journée particulière aux états unis où
l'on
les funérailles pardon de georges klein
se poursuivent cet homme symbole
désormais de la lutte antiraciste est
inhumé à houston la ville où il a grandi
des funérailles privées mais beaucoup
d'américains ont fait le déplacement
hier des milliers d'anonymes ont
également bravé la chaleur pour venir
saluer et saluer la dépouille de georges
floyd exposés à l'intérieur d'une église
à houston en madone à mon dieu il a
l'air en paix même si nous savons ce qui
s'est passé mais de la façon dont ils
ont fait des choses
il a l'air en paix il a l'air calme et
il a l'air plutôt ils ont fait du bon
travail
vraiment on voudrait passer un peu plus
de temps avec lui juste lui montrer
notre respect et être près de lui avoir
un moment avec lui mais c'est si court
mais je suis vraiment contente d'être
venue
on a fait la queue pendant plus de cinq
six heures et je suis vraiment super
content d'être venu
ça valait le coup et c'est un sentiment
d'euphorie parce que ça arrive trop tard
pour les personnes noires ça dépasse le
lycée de georges floyd ça dépasse le
quartier dans lequel il a grandi ça
dépasse l'église
il est temps de mettre fin à
l'oppression des personnes noires
regardez c'est houston texas nous sommes
le melting-pot des états unis j'ai vous
voyez des gens ici noir blanc
hispaniques asiatiques du moyen-orient
européen
tout le monde est là en paix pour
célébrer une vie qui n'aurait pas dû
être perdus et pour voir l'esprit
américain l'action nous sommes très
enthousiastes et pour en parler nous
sommes avec ben swan journaliste
d'investigation en direct d'atlanta aux
états unis bonsoir ben soit 2 merci
d'être avec nous
émotion évidemment on imagine aux états
unis aujourd'hui toutes les chaînes de
télé sont branchés sur ses funérailles
tout à fait ce genre de mouvement est
très fédérateur pour le pays il ya une
petite manifestation sinon bradley
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
manifestaient et tout cela centré autour
de cette personnalité de georges flotte
donc aujourd'hui ses funérailles sont
vraiment un moment clé la famille de
georges feuilla et demandé plus d'union
dans le pays et des changements oignons
de jazz flotte donc il y à beaucoup de
changements et et des véritables
changements dans toutes les villes des
états unis liées à ce décès beaucoup
d'émotion beaucoup d'importance donnée
cet événement dans le pays ça veut dire
clairement bensman qu'on doit s'attendre
aujourd'hui à de véritables changements
justement historique y aura vraiment
véritablement en avant et un après selon
vous mais je le pense mais je crois
l'avoir déjà évoqué le mouvement black
l'animateur a commencé il ya cinq ans il
a fallu cinq ans pour arriver à ce point
et c'est un peu tragique de voir combien
d'hommes politiques si du côté de ce
parti maintenant mais ils ignoraient
totalement il y a cinq ans il ya
beaucoup de trucs personnes noires qui
sont mortes dans les rues des états unis
mais si l'on veut regarder au delà de
george clooney était peut-être
effectivement qu'il y aura un avant et
un après il a fallu beaucoup de temps
avant d'arriver à ce point mais
effectivement il y a des demandes
pour le changement le public a
véritablement changé et c'est eux qui
ont mené ces manifestations on a vu des
personnes de tous les horizons se
rassembler ces manifestations sont
véritablement interculturel inter
géographique intergénérationnel donc ce
sont des personnes de tous les horizons
qui se rassemblent et donc les milieux
politiques qui se sont maintenant du
côté des manifestants
donc il pourrait effectivement y avoir
de véritables changements
la question c'est est-ce que l'on
changements sont ils véritablement
réduire le nombre des morts inutiles
non seulement pour les personnes de
couleur mais ferait table pour tout le
monde on verra alors vous le dis dans
les politiques se mettent du côté des
manifestants
joe biden n'a pas loupé le coche en
pleine campagne présidentielle joe biden
qui nous dit le candidat démocrate
l'heure de la justice raciale est venu
ça peut être surprenant de la part
justement de joe biden il tire il essaye
de tirer son épingle du jeu tout à fait
ils essayent de tirer son épingle du jeu
il n'a pas un très bon passif avec ce
genre d'organisation je pense qu'il
l'ait fait que suivre le mouvement
ils assez d'autres personnalités
politiques qui a mené le mouvement et
les suies jobs hayden est très en retard
par rapport à beaucoup d'autres
personnalités politiques comme par
exemple adam harris beaucoup de
personnes s'expriment sur ces sujets
depuis des années et lui est resté très
silencieux dont ils arrivent en retard
mais il est c'est effectivement de se
mettre du côté qui le soutiendra lors
des élections
c'est facile de le faire aujourd'hui
alors que donald trump s'exprime avec
tant de force contre les manifestants il
a même évoqué l'idée de déployer l'armée
donc en se mettant en se plaçant contre
trump il se place facilement et sans
beaucoup d'effort dans ce contexte de
besoins de changement qui vient donc de
la population vous l'avez bien expliqués
en train joe biden
ce qui revient à un petit peu voilà sur
ce qu'il a dit personne n'est dupe
manifestement on avait encore un invité
tout à l'heure d'une association de
minneapolis vous vous l'avez bien
expliqué et un donald trump qui lui sont
tient vraiment férocement la police est
ce qu'il ya vraiment un candidat à la
présidentielle qui est à la hauteur de
cette situation de ces enjeux
aujourd'hui président des états unis le
président des états unis a très peu de
contrôles très peu de pouvoir sur la
police car les départements des polices
sont dirigées par les états ou dans la
majorité des cas par les bibles il met
ses qualités
ceux ci sont bien que les conseils
municipaux et les maires qui ont le
pouvoir sur les stratégies policière sur
le budget policiers sur le comportement
des policiers s'il y a des instances de
contrôle grippe a donc c'est vraiment au
niveau local que les choses se passent
et les candidats présidentiels vont
beaucoup parlé de ce sujet l'on ne peut
faire quasiment rien pour changer la
situation
la police doit changer au niveau local
au niveau communautaire c'est pourquoi
beaucoup de manifestants demandent à ce
qu'on coupe les vivres au département de
police
mais cela devrait passer par les
candidats à la mairie et non pas par le
président vous dites ça passe au niveau
local mais pour insuffler vraiment
véritablement changement de mentalité ça
doit passer peut-être par un leader le
leader d'un pays mais les idées
effectivement n'apparaîtront peut-être
pas au niveau local
lorsqu'à différents
communauté une ferrand différentes
villes on a différents du doctor who qui
voit différents problèmes
effectivement il fait des dirigeants au
niveau national pour que un véritable
mouvement national se développent les en
matière de changement concret par
exemple la baisse la réduction des
budgets des départements de police
je suis las de se faire au niveau et de
toutes les communautés de toutes les
municipalités et pas au niveau national
donc chaque maire doit décider de les
faire à son niveau
nancy pas là donc c'est une
c'est un sujet très compliqué est ce
qu'on fera véritablement un changement
rapide dans les idées et des principes
peuvent fédérer mais en vérité dans les
actes c'est une situation tout à fait
différente
merci vençoise rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste d'investigation directe
d'attentats merci à vous première ville
a touché par le cos vite 19 la ville on
s'en souvient de hunan en chine qui a
rouvert ses universités hier une partie
à des étudiants sont autorisés à
retourner sur le campus priorité aux
élèves en fin de parcours et aux
diplômés ayant des activités de
recherche scientifique berceau de la
pandémie est cité chinoise entamé à des
mesures de déconfinement début avril
cette réouverture des universités marque
donc une étape importante dans le pays
une décision saluée par de nombreux
habitants comme les étudiants retournent
progressivement au cours l'université
normale de la chine centrale demande aux
étudiants de scanner un qr code et de se
faire contrôler leur température
corporelle
si rien est anormal l'étudiant peut
entrer sur le campus
enfin je retourne à l'université
cela fait longtemps que je n'y étais pas
retourné je me sens bien maintenant
j'espère que nous pourrons bientôt
enlever nos masques
pendant le coït 19 notre petite
entreprise a été affecté surtout notre
magasin qui est près de l'université
normale de la chine centrale
mais maintenant les étudiants sont de
retour et je pense que ça va aller mieux
j'espère que le coït 19 partira vite au
vietnam suite à la pandémie de
coronavirus les agriculteurs et
producteurs de nichi peine à écouler
leurs stocks les frontières ouvertes est
pour les marchandises reste encore
fermée aux étrangers ce qui contribue à
la chute des prix les explications en
images avec les niveaux
comme chaque année de la mi mai à la mi
juin
c'est l'heure de la récolte pour l'un
des plus grands exportateurs de litchi
au monde le vietnam une récolte qui ne
dure que six semaines six semaines donc
pour écouler les stocks aux clients
vietnamiens mais surtout aux clients
internationaux problème en raison de la
crise économique liée à la pandémie de
coronavirus les agriculteurs lutte pour
écouler leur production
ils ne voient pas cette année les
acheteurs étrangers venir au marché de
gros pour réaliser leurs transactions en
direct car ils sont bloqués dans leur
pays
cette année en raison de la pandémie on
ne voit pas de commerçants chinois
donc on a surtout vendu à des
commerçants nationaux le prix est donc
très bas le prix augmente normalement
s'il ya des consommateurs étrangers car
ils veulent des litchis de haute qualité
beau et gros pour la consommation
intérieure le prix est plus bas et les
gens ne veulent pas que les litchis soit
gros c'est pourquoi le prix national
varie beaucoup
j'espère vraiment que plus de
commerçants arriveront pour consommer
les litchis de l'uqam gagnent j'espère
que les marchandises passent auront
facilement la frontière pour que l'élite
y puisse passer son problème
considéré comme le royaume des litchis
le vietnam exporte habituellement pas
moins de cent mille tonnes de litchis
préparant ses clients principaux étant
la chine l'australie et les etats-unis
ces dernières années le pis et tourner
massivement vers l'exportation de fruits
et légumes
en 2009 ils en ont écoulé pour plus de
trois milliards d'euros mais les
exportateurs vietnamiens de fruits sont
affectés cette année par la flambée des
prix du fret aérien en raison du nombre
limité de vols commerciaux suite à la
crise sanitaire
malgré une demande élevée les
exportations ont diminué de moitié au
cours des deux derniers mois
si les restrictions de déplacement à
l'intérieur du pays ont été assouplies
depuis le début du mois de mai par le
gouvernement vietnamien
aucune date n'a encore été annoncée
concernant une possible réouverture des
frontières
pour rappel le vietnam est l'un des pays
les moins touchés au monde malgré sa
frontière commune avec la chine il ne
recense à ce jour que 332 cas de
coronavirus et aucun décès à 7 et il ya
un an jour pour jour à hong kong le 9
juin 2010 9,1 millions de manifestants
descendus dans la rue pour protester
contre un projet de loi controversé
un texte autorisant les extraditions
vers la chine continentale
un an plus tard les hong kong et sont à
nouveau mobilisés et la mairie tél
après une accalmie pendant la pandémie
de coronavirus les contestataires ont
investi à nouveau les trottoirs de
centrales coeur financier de l'ex
colonie britannique
mais l'ampleur des manifestations est
désormais limité par un important
dispositif policier malgré tout les
voies de la rue porte toujours les
stigmates d'une mobilisation sans
précédent depuis la rétrocession en 1997
après douze mois les gens se mobilisent
toujours ici pour montrer au
gouvernement et au reste du monde que
nous nous battons toujours pour nos
droits
que nous battons toujours pour notre
liberté que l'on nous battons toujours
pour notre démocratie et que nous
voulons montrer au monde que nous ne
sommes pas encore entrés chez nous que
nous n'avons pas encore abandonné nous
n'avons pas d'armes et nous n'avons pas
d'armes dont cette manifestation est la
seule chose que nous pouvons faire pour
dire au monde ce que nous pensons et ce
pourquoi nous nous battons nous sommes
ici pour rappeler à hong kong que nous
avons traversé une période très
difficile l'année dernière et nous
aimerions que le monde entier se
joignent à nous pour éliminer le virus
parti communiste chinois de la planète
[Applaudissements]
les nombreuses arrestations lors des
manifestations précédentes pas moins de
9000 ans porté un sérieux coup au
mouvement qui a réuni une foule moins
importante ce mardi s'ajoutent à cela
les mesures prises par les autorités
pour lutter contre le coc vite 19 tout
rassemblement de plus de huit personnes
est interdite à hong kong
la police anti émeutes est d'ailleurs
intervenue rapidement ce jour
anniversaire
les forces de l'ordre ont tenté de
disperser les protestataires et procédé
à plusieurs arrestations
[Applaudissements]
un an après le début de la contestation
déclenchée par la loi autorisant les
extraditions vers la chine continentale
les tensions politiques demeurent très
fortes la loi sur la sécurité nationale
qui vise à réprimer les activités
séparatistes devrait entrer en vigueur à
hong kong cet été et c'est en cette
journée bien particulière que la chef de
l'exécutif
hong kong et s'est exprimé pour appeler
à la fin des manifestations au cours de
l'année écoulée hong kong a fait face à
de nombreuses difficultés cela est clair
pour tous c'est grave des filles ont
provoqué un travail que nous sommes en
train d'accomplir tout le monde doit
apprendre sa leçon y compris le
gouvernement de hong kong
j'espère que les membres du conseil
législatif apprendront leur leçon que
hong kong ne peut supporter ce genre de
chaos et que les hong kong et veulent un
environnement stable et pacifique pour
pouvoir vivre et travailler de manière
heureuse à l'étang wang wang
pas sûr que le message soit entendu par
les contestataires
des groupes d'étudiants et des syndicats
ont d'ores et déjà fait part de leur
intention de sonder leurs adhérents sur
un éventuel mouvement de grève dans les
prochains jours mais c'est la fin de
cette émission merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouvera en quelques petites minutes
pour 1 point complet sur l'actuelle
[Musique]
ici on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne au profit
de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président très pratique et le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale
si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts pour
rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie on
nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe
c'est à dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant mais
on recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura l'inde et baltique
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux etats unis les funérailles de
giorgio et dans l'intimité à houston ils
sont venus nombreux se recueillir en sa
mémoire dans sa ville natale depuis la
mort de cet homme froid mairie 15 fixé
par un policier
mais les effets la réforme et la police
multiplient partout dans le pays ce qui
fragilise la campagne de donald trump au
profit de son rival joe biden nouveau
rassemblement et hommage ce soir dans
l'hexagone pour saluer la mémoire de
jean jeu fun justement et combattre le
racisme dans la police notamment
elle place de la république à paris
edouard philippe appelle au respect à la
confiance mais aussi l exigence
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre au
lendemain des mesures dévoilées par
christophe castaner la gestion de la
crise sanitaire en france sur le grill
une enquête préliminaire a été ouverte
par le procureur de la république de
paris
depuis le 24 mars dernier il a reçu 60
de plaintes ou signalements l'enquète
portent notamment sur la mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui et non assistance à
personne en péril
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france une journée
particulière donc aux états unis avec
les funérailles de john floyd cet homme
désormais symbole de la lutte
antiraciste va être inhumé dans quelques
instants à houston de sa ville natale
des funérailles privées mais beaucoup
d'américains lui ont rendu hommage dans
les rues hier des milliers d'anonymes
ont bravé la chaleur pour venir saluer
sa dépouille exposée à l'intérieur d'une
église à houston en madone à mon dieu il
a l'air en paix même si nous savons ce
qui s'est passé mais de la façon dont
ils ont fait des choses
il a l'air en paix il a l'air calme et
il a l'air plutôt ils ont fait du bon
travail
vraiment on voudrait passer un peu plus
de temps avec lui juste lui montrer
notre respect et être près de lui avoir
un moment avec lui mais c'est si court
mais je suis vraiment contente d'être
venue
on a fait la queue pendant plus de cinq
six heures et je suis vraiment super
content d'être venu
ça valait le coup et c'est un sentiment
d'euphorie parce que ça arrive trop tard
pour les personnes noires ça dépasse le
lycée de georges floyd ça dépasse le
quartier dans lequel il a grandi ça
dépasse l'église
il est temps de mettre fin à
l'oppression des personnes noires
regardez c'est houston texas nous sommes
le melting-pot des états unis j'ai vous
voyez des gens ici noir blanc
hispaniques asiatiques du moyen-orient
européen
tout le monde est là en paix pour
célébrer une vie qui n'aurait pas dû
être perdus et pour voir l'esprit
américain en action nous sommes très
enthousiastes et le procès de derek
chauvin a débuté hier accusé du meurtre
de john floyd sa caution a été fixée à 1
million $
il comparaissait pour la première fois
devant un juge par vidéoconférence il
est incarcéré dans une prison fédérale
de haute sécurité il risque jusqu'à 40
ans de réclusion trois de ses anciens
collègues présents lors de l'arrestation
de georges floyd sont inculpés de
complicité de meurtre elle date de la
prochaine audience a été fixée au 29
juin et à la fin du mois de mai les
manifestations contre la mort de georges
de floride avait donc
ok imbert dans différentes villes du
pays ce n'est pas la première fois que
les émeutes raciales éclate après des
bavures de policiers aux états unis
retour en images
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour dave be king membre du conseil
d'administration des communautés unis
contre la brutalité policière la
décision d'abolir la police de
minneapolis est une manipulation des
dirigeants politiques pour éluder le
vrai débat il utilise cette idée afin de
repousser la discussion sur les
problèmes les origines du problème là où
ils ont refusé de mettre en place de
mettre en oeuvre des réformes faisable
il préfère qu'il n'y ait pas de réformes
et que rien ne se passe du tout en fin
de compte donc il est important de
discuter au sein du public sur à quoi
ressemblerait une ville sans police il
est encore plus important en tout cas de
travailler sur des réformes profondes et
véritables qui pourrait changer la
stratégie policière
dès maintenant nous avons une liste de
44 réforme qui pourrait pourrait être
mis en oeuvre immédiatement et qui se
sont montrés par le passé comme étant
très efficace et capable de d'améliorer
la police il ne faut pas laisser nos
élus ch faire ce qu'il souhaite en
disant simplement qu'il faut abolir la
police ils n'ont rien fait on paris
lille grenoble dijon ou encore à me
après les mobilisations de la semaine
dernière nouveau rassemblement et
hommage dans plusieurs villes de france
le rendez vous était fixé à 18 heures à
laquelle heures laquelle ont débuté et
justement les obsèques de georges floyd
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
plusieurs syndicats partis politiques
organisations étudiantes et ong se sont
associés à l'appel à manifester lancé
par sos racisme pour combattre le
racisme dans la police dans la capitale
rassemblement place de la république on
fait le point avec notre reporter katia
technique
le rassemblement mémoire de georges
floyd a démarré
18 heures place de la république des
milliers de personnes avaient répondu à
l'appel des sceaux s racisme des
milliers de citoyens mais aussi de très
nombreux élus comme le sénateur
socialiste david assouline des ong des
partis politiques comme le parti
communiste et bien sûr bien sûr des
citoyens venus rendre un dernier hommage
alors pas n'importe comment c'était une
action symbolique huit minutes 46 de
silence le genou à terre et bien
évidemment ça représente la durée
pendant laquelle georges floyd ce
citoyen noir américain a eu le coup
compressés par le genou d'un policier
blanc des règles aux vingt huit longues
minutes une minute 46 pendant lesquelles
il s'est asphyxié progressivement tout
en suppliant qu'on desserrent l'étreinte
voilà donc une tragédie qui a été
aujourd'hui est commémorée par ces
milliers de citoyens très calme dans une
ambiance très solennelle mais aussi
combative
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet la
vice-présidente d'espèces racisme si on
a tenu à organiser cet hommage avec
autant de jeunes aujourd'hui à 18 heures
place de la république c'est parce qu'en
même temps à 11h à houston était
organisé les obsèques de georges floyd
noir mort parce que noir par un
représentant de l'état par un policier
aux états unis même si ça s'est passé
aux états unis
ça a cristallisé une émotion et une
colère particulière en france puisque
nous jeunes en france nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas hors sujet de ce
phénomène qu'est le racisme dans la
police c'était normal d'être là contre
ce racisme contre 7 ses façons de faire
autoritaire de la police ça fait un clin
d'oeil à ce qui se passe aussi en france
même si les chaussons
pas les mêmes néanmoins moi je suis élue
de seine-saint-denis on peut pas dire
que tout se passe dans le meilleur des
mondes
la police est une la sécurité est un
droit essentiel
ça touche les plus faibles la police se
doit être exemplaire et quand on est
exemplaire
on peut pas être des fidèles de temps
c'est beaucoup plus médiatisée tabac et
du coup il ya un réveil des fruits par
rapport à la situation d'il ya entre
guillemets toujours existé et elle
accepte est bon de dire entre états unis
mais aussi en france à l'égard des
minorités de manière générale je pense
qu'il ya un mouvement historique qui est
en train de s'établir pour la première
fois dans toute l'humanité part de tous
les pays on se rend compte enfants qu'
il n'y a plus de place à la
discrimination quelle qu'elle soit plus
placé à l'antisémitisme plus de place au
racisme
tout le monde se mobilise et s'élève
d'un seul d'un seul homme pour dire non
pour dire que voilà on a connu une
période très dure au niveau de la
pandémie qui n'est pas terminée et que
l'humanité a pris le dessus sur j'espère
le capitalisme et que c'est plus
possible actuellement une équipe de
dénigrer du mans alors d'une prise de
conscience internationale et bien
d'autres rassemblements manifestations
vont être prévues comme par exemple le
13 juin en mémoire de dame à traoré en
tout cas pour cet hommage à georges
floyd tout s'est déroulé dans un calme
absolu
les personnes qui sont rassemblés se
dispersent et les organisateurs ont bien
tenu à préciser nous garderons notre
dignité et notre pacifisme et dans ce
contexte de dénonciation des violences
policières le gouvernement affiche sa
mobilisation
un mot d'ordre depuis hier tolérance
zéro contre le racisme edouard philippe
et christophe castaner était à évrier la
rencontre des policiers qui travaillent
dans le quartier
dans les quartiers difficiles le premier
ministre reconnaît une émotion très
grande très légitime est très partagée
vis-à-vis des violences policières
présumées
je suis en essonne dans un département
ou à de nombreuses reprises les forces
de l'ordre les gardiens de la paix ont
été victimes d'attaqués physiques terry
gardiens de la paix les forces de
l'ordre qui assure notre protection
nous leur devons respect et confiance
l'immense majorité des français à vis à
vis de nos forces de l'ordre de nos
gardiens de la paix respect et confiance
et parce que nous devons avoir respect
et confiance à des femmes et des hommes
qui s'engagent dans des missions
redoutablement difficile est essentielle
nous avons également un devoir
d'exigence vis-à-vis d'elle vis-à-vis de
la vérité c'est que le racisme est une
une forme de maladie de l'âme une forme
de faiblesse
il faut savoir que nous devons tous être
à la hauteur des principes de la
république
en étant exigeant vis-à-vis de ce qu'ils
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
comme en étant exigeant vis-à-vis de
soi-même mais les méthodes d'
arrestations policières de plus en plus
décrié c'est christophe castaner a
annoncé l'abandon de la technique dite
de l'étranglement hier lors d'une
conférence de presse qu'en est-il de
celle du placage ventrale c'est la
question que pose la famille d'éric
souvient au ministre de l'intérieur dans
une lettre publiée hier
cet homme de 42 ans est mort en janvier
dernier après un maintien au sol par des
policiers lors d'un contrôle d'identité
musclés une position qui empêchent de
respirer correctement selon les ong
amnesty international et puis d'après un
dernier rapport elle serait aussi
responsable de la mort d'adama traoré la
famille elle eric souvient réclame
l'interdiction de cette méthode
les annonces de christophe castaner ne
sont pas suffisantes car elles sont
singulières et n'entraîne pas de
stratégie globale
s'agissant de violences policières il ya
à la fois une impunité une augmentation
concernant ces recours à la force
et pour christian scholly ap
de cédric joue via décédé le 5 janvier
dernier d'une asphyxie deux jours après
son interpellation sur le quai branly
dans le 7e arrondissement de paris
l'abandon la technique dite de
l'étranglement est loin d'être suffisant
sipa une vraie victoire
tiens tiens un tout petit filet parce
que le plaquage ventrale est aussi
dangereux quand vous avez deux trois
gars sur votre dos qui maintient le tome
1 des ça peut faire deux à trois cents
kilos vous avez ça sur le dos vous avez
le ventre meurtri j'avais tout cas toute
la chaîne de commande à respiratoire qui
est complètement bloqué
donc aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que
c'est une victoire aujourd'hui ça a
réveillé les grandes instances notre
président s'est manifestée parce qu'on
n'avait rien après jusqu'à présent et ce
week-end lui la sphère de charge
comment aux états unis il a compris
qu'il a compris qu'il y avait un vrai
problème
il fallait faire quelque chose et d'un
seul coup on sort du chapeau
on va arrêter le lac et des tremblements
ça sera déjà une bonne chose ça va les
calmer la famille shaw bien n'est pas
calmé la famille traoré n'est pas cad
comme à manacor elle n'est pas calmé on
nous errons donne des miettes donc on
vous raconte
voilà moi je suis pas d'accord avec tout
ce qui a été dit j'ai croisé monsieur
castaner ce matin je lui ai dit en face
entre quatre yeux ce que je pensais et
il m'a même dit vous ne m'en voulez un
petit peu aujourd'hui
en ce moment vous avez un petit peu
après j'ai dit je n'ai pas ap london la
ministre voit la différence
à présent le bilan du coronavirus dont
l'hexagone le nom de personnes en
réanimation continue de baisser avec
moins de 1000 malades selon la direction
générale de la santé est la france
enregistré 87 morts liés aux côtés des
oeuvres dans les hôpitaux ces dernières
24 heures au total 20 pouces 1280 seize
personnes sont mortes depuis le début de
l'épidémie
la chancelière angela merkel et le
président macron prince l'union
européenne dans une lettre de se
préparer à une prochaine éventuelle
pandémie
dans la lignée de la demande du
gouvernement emmanuel macron aurait
demandé à nicole belloubet de se pencher
un peu plus sur la sphère d'adama traoré
la ministre de la justice a donc voulu
inviter les proches de ce dernier à la
rencontrer pour échanger
mais la famille du jeune homme mort en
2016 lors d'une interpellation de
l'adresse une fin de non-recevoir alliés
attendre les avancées judiciaire et non
des invitations à la discussion qui
n'auraient aucune finalité procédurale
l'avocat de la famille met également en
avant la séparation des pouvoirs et la
soeur damas traoré la justice a laissé
les deux témoins que nous demandons
depuis quatre ans des témoins que nous
demandons à être entendu les témoins
principaux dans la mort de mon petit
frère
une femme et l'homme qui était dans
l'appartement
ça fait quatre ans que nous demandons à
la justice que la justice refuse à
refuser faut savoir que notre avocat
maître yassine bouzrou a demandé
plusieurs actes est quasiment à chaque
fois tous les actes sont refusés donc
aujourd'hui un rapport de force a été
installé une petite victoire
sauf que c'est pas une petite victoire
que nous voulons hier le président s'est
exprimé à demander à ce que le ministre
de la justice puisse se saisir de la
sphère d'adama traoré le ministre de la
justice a contacté notre avocat maître
yassine bouzrou pour nous rencontrer
sauf qu'aujourd'hui le ministre de la
justice ne doit pas rencontrer la
famille traoré
mais le ministre de la justice doit
rencontrer le procureur on rappelle
qu'il ya séparation entre l'état et la
justice
on ne demande pas à ce que les
discussions se fassent dans un salon de
thé de l'elysée
on demande que des actes judiciaires
soient faits en gestion de crise au
coeur des tribunaux le parquet de paris
a ouvert une vaste enquête préliminaire
sur la gestion de la crise lié aux
coronavirus particulier syndicats ou
encore associations mettent en cause
notamment plusieurs
départements ministériels et
responsables administratifs les
explications en images
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l' enquête pénale n'est pas là pour
définir des responsabilités politiques
ou administratives mais pour mettre au
jour d'éventuelles infractions pénales
s'il ya des fautes pénales seront très
probablement c'est une hypothèse d faute
non intentionnelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
écoutez ce sujet les explications de
florence bouquet vice-présidente du
collectif interlock regroupant des
infirmiers travaillant en bloc
opératoire ils ont décidé de déposer
plainte contre l'ensemble des directions
des 32 chu de france
nous ce qu'on voudrait faire c'est faire
remonter toutes les têtes la défaillance
qui a eu par rapport à notre gouvernance
en fait on a un système d' entité
décisionnel qui a dit qu'il ya dix et
qui a fait aussi un peu n'importe quoi
est ce qu'on concernant le matériel on
l'a bien vu avec donc notamment les les
masques le gel les blessures blues
qu'est-ce qu'on a eu d'autres également
on a eu par rapport au respirateur aussi
il ya eu d énormément de deux
respirateurs qui ont été commandés et
qui en fait n'était pas du tout adaptée
pour le les patients dans la prise en
charge des patients qu'on vide il ya eu
toutes ces transport de patients
c'est ça a été fait par les hélicoptères
les comment le le porte hélicoptères
tonnerre tout cela engendrait beaucoup
de frais et c'était pas en fait
justifiée il y avait des établissements
privés qui étaient beaucoup plus près
que les 800 kilomètres qui ont été
nécessaires pour transférer des patients
de de mulhouse à toulouse et je pense
que voilà il ya une gestion qui a été
désastreuse
à sa tête il ya un an jour pour jour
kong le 9 juin 2010 9,1 millions de
manifestants descendus dans la rue pour
protester contre un projet de loi
controversé un texte autorisant les
extraditions mention envers la chine
continentale
un an plus tard les hong kong et sont à
nouveau mobilisés et l'âme et medjahed
après une accalmie pendant la pandémie
de couronnes un virus les contestataires
ont investi à nouveau les trottoirs de
centrales coeur financier de l'ex
colonie britannique
mais l'ampleur des manifestations est
désormais limité par un important
dispositif policier malgré tout les
voies de la rue porte toujours les
stigmates d'une mobilisation sans
précédent depuis la rétrocession en 1997
après douze mois les gens se mobilisent
toujours ici pour montrer au
gouvernement et au reste du monde que
nous nous battons toujours sur nos
droits de l'homme que nous battons
toujours pour notre liberté que nous
nous battons toujours pour notre
démocratie et que nous voulons montrer
au monde que nous ne sommes pas encore
entrés chez nous que nous n'avons pas
encore abandonné nous n'avons pas
d'armes et nous n'avons pas d'armes donc
cette manifestation est la seule chose
que nous pouvons faire pour dire au
monde ce que nous pensons et ce pourquoi
nous nous battons nous sommes ici pour
rappeler en compte que nous avons
traversé une période très difficile
l'année dernière et nous aimerions que
le monde entier se joignent à nous pour
éliminer le virus parti communiste
chinois de la planète
[Applaudissements]
les nombreuses arrestations lors des
manifestations précédentes pas moins de
9000 ans porté un sérieux coup au
mouvement qui a réuni une foule moins
importante ce mardi s'ajoutent à cela
les mesures prises par les autorités
pour lutter contre le coc vite 19 tout
rassemblement de plus de huit personnes
est interdite à hong kong
la police anti émeutes est d'ailleurs
intervenue rapidement ce jour
anniversaire
les forces de l'ordre ont tenté de
disperser les protestataires et procédé
à plusieurs arrestations
[Applaudissements]
un an après le début de la contestation
déclenchée par la loi autorisant les
extraditions vers la chine continentale
les tensions politiques demeurent très
fortes la loi sur la sécurité nationale
qui vise à réprimer les activités
séparatistes devrait entrer en vigueur
en compte cet été et c'est en cette
journée bien particulière que la chef de
l'exécutif
hong kong et s'est exprimé pour appeler
à la fin des manifestations au cours de
l'année écoulée hong kong a fait face à
de nombreuses difficultés
cela est clair pour tous c'est grave des
filles ont provoqué un travail que nous
sommes en train d'accomplir tout le
monde doit apprendre sa leçon y compris
le gouvernement de hong kong
j'espère que les membres du conseil
législatif apprendront leur leçon que
hong kong ne peut supporter ce genre de
chaos et que les hong kong et veulent un
environnement stable et pacifique pour
pouvoir vivre et travailler de manière
heureuse et dans mon collègue
pas sûr que le message soit entendu par
les contestataires
des groupes d'étudiants et des syndicats
ont d'ores et déjà fait part de leur
intention de sonder leurs adhérents sur
un éventuel mouvement de grève dans les
prochains jours l'épidémie de
coronavirus s'aggrave dans le monde
notamment en amérique du fus de
déclarations de l'om est ce pays le plus
touché est du continent le brésil qui a
pourtant entamé son déconfinement
stratégies différentes en argentine au
chili au pérou qui eux sont toujours
confinés malgré les difficultés pour la
population à respecter les mesures dans
un contexte économique difficile
françois tessier beach jusqu'à 10 km de
bouchons ce lundi matin à rio de janeiro
trois semaines que ce n'est pas arrivé
dans la ville carioca
la veille le maire marcel écrivez-le a
approuvé le redémarrage des activités
commerciales
car au brésil ce sont les autorités
locales qui prennent leurs propres
décisions sur le calendrier le processus
et des étapes de la reprise de
l'activité sociale terrain de football
bars restaurants et centres commerciaux
de l'état de rio de janeiro ont été
autorisés à rouve
hier un des confinement qui pose
question alors qu'avec près de soixante
dix mille cas la ville carioca et sa
région est l'une des plus touchées par
la pandémie au brésil deux stratégies
différentes en argentine où le
déconfinement du pays n'est pas attendu
avant le 28 juin
mais ce lundi soir joggeurs cyclistes
marcheurs et sportifs en tous genres ont
pu retrouver les rues de buenos aires s
après la levée des restrictions
concernant les activités physiques en
plein air il est temps de revenir devant
changer un peu d'air
même son nom fermé depuis plus de 70
jours où je ne sais pas combien de temps
80 jeux eux-mêmes et nous en avions
vraiment besoin pour notre santé et
notre bien-être aussi un confinement
débuté le 20 mars est particulièrement
stricte port du masque obligatoire dans
tous les espace public y compris la rue
demande de ne pas prendre les transports
en commun et nécessité d'un justificatif
pour sortir de son quartier cole
suspendu
des mesures qui ont permis au pays
d'être beaucoup moins touché que ses
voisins brésiliens et chiliens au chili
justement pays où le nombre d'infections
par million d'habitants est le plus
élevé au monde
la population est confinée depuis 11
semaines un confinement difficilement
maintenu par les autorités qui ont
décidé de renforcer les contrôles
policiers dans les quartiers de la
capitale chilienne
nous sommes en train d'effectuer une
mission dans le centre de santiago
parce que les gens ont été négligents
ils ont été responsables et nous avons
maintenant on semaine de quarantaine et
plus de 2000 morts un confinement devenu
également dit
souvent supportable pour les péruviens
deuxième pays le plus touché du
continent en quarantaine depuis le 16
mars le perron a décidé de la prolonger
jusqu'au 30 juin soit le confinement le
plus long au monde
du lundi au samedi entre 21h et 4 heures
du matin et toute la journée du dimanche
la population doit rester chez elle
pourtant des millions de péruviens
continue de vendre des produits dans les
rues pour pouvoir survivre
une crise sanitaire qui se transforme en
crise économique
40% des péruviens ont perdu la totalité
de leur revenu
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité demain 7h du matin heure
française quand à moi j'aurai le plaisir
de vous retrouver à 20 heures demain
soir
[Musique]
they serait-ce mauvaises récoltes
canicule il y avait beaucoup de bétail
avant aujourd'hui il est impossible
d'avoir des animaux
rien ne pousse ici que mangerait les
animaux le climat de la terre est
aujourd'hui plus chaud qui ne l'a été au
cours des cent mille dernières années
[Musique]
pas d'eau pour la maison pas d'eau pour
se laver
à la fin du siècle
il fera encore plus chaud
[Musique]
le moment est venu de réfléchir à la
façon d'en gérer les conséquences
comment nous sauver cela entraînera
d'importants bouleversements à quel
impact faut-il s'attendre
seront ils visible dans l'environnement
l'économie et la politique
personne ne le sait